wow today certainly was uh pretty wild
as the evening picked up so uh the house
has voted to formalize the impeachment
inquiry impeachment is on Hunter Biden
defied his subpoena and the GOP says
they're going to hold him in contempt he
gave a speech instead the judge has
suspended uh in Trump's election
interference case suspended it pending a
result in whether in the hearing of as
to whether or not Trump's immune scoas
has granted CT to the obstruction charge
in the j6 cases it's been an absolutely
wild day and uh man we got so much to
talk about uh uh Tucker Carlson has
joined Rumble oh boy man so I guess
we're going to get into all of that plus
uh big debate on on the budlight
question and we've got one of the best
people in the world here with us to talk
about all that before we get started my
friends head over to the best song
ever.com and boy do we got a deal for
you you go to the bestsong ever.com and
you can pre-order our new song together
again and I'll tell you why you should
we put out a song we put out several
songs we get mercilessly attacked for no
reason and we even had people in the
music industry tell us to F ourselves
the songs were not political they were
fairly basic because they don't want us
winning the culture War so you know what
we decided to do we were going to put
together a song called is this what you
want which was going to be synth pop
modern garbage but the joke was not is
this what you want girl but like is this
what you the the music industry wants
instead we decided to team up with the
daily wire make a cover of their song
together again which was also their big
Fu to the music industry that told them
they would not accept 100 times the
standard licensing rate to play a song
once for political reasons I would
assume so this song is coming out on
Friday and we're hoping to shatter
billboard we've gotten three of the last
four songs out that we've released
hitting billboard uh we didn't really
promote the the last one but I'm fairly
confident this one will reach billboard
and we want to because we want to
continually invade their spaces go to
the best song.com
pre-order together again and guess what
what you do you'll get a promo code that
gives you 35% off your next order of
cast Brew Coffee the song is for sale at
69 and then you can use that to save
loads when you order cast brew coffee
from cprw coffee.com including
subscriptions now I'm not 100% positive
CU I'm tell my team right now what we
want to happen is if you pre-order the
song and get the promo code then go to
Cas brew.com And subscribe to the coffee
Club I want that 35% to be forever
forever meaning if you sign up and then
in six months you cancel because you
can't afford it but then three months
later you sign back up the discount
reapplies itself I don't know if we can
do that but I'm telling you guys I want
this to be the case every single month
you'll get 35% off basically means you
get a bag for free so uh there you go
the best song ever.com help us give a
big fat middle finger to the industry
and we've got Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles they're in the music video it's a
it's a funny bit the basically the whole
thing is a bit of a gag but it's modern
synth pop I hope you enjoy it don't
forget to also head over to
timcast.net smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and beer is Seth
weathers I just downloaded and paid 69
cents for the song on Amazon all right
let's go so feel like I'm part of it all
great to be here it's definitely a good
day to be here for with everything going
on in the Beer World we've got some
calendars we got a lot of exciting stuff
happening you're the beer guy you're the
guy who when Bud Light came out and did
this whole Dyan Mia thing you said you
know we're going to make our own beer as
we should and uh I got to be honest
everybody here is such a fan of your
beer you asked me if we had any and I'm
like dude if you if you bring like 10
cases they'll be gone in the week pretty
sure you had half a pallet but we'll
send you more I think we did well it's
like it's good and people uh like
hanging out after work or whatever
having a beer and it's just it's just
instantly gone so we were actually
debating a little bit about what's going
on with the Bud Light stuff but I think
I would defer to you as someone who
actually knows how to ship sell and deal
with beer and you actually have a
calendar of conservative beautiful women
that you just put out so I I'll say for
the show but uh I mean you you've also
done other things in the past with uh
wrapping paper right right uh well we're
I'm all beer all the time now it's um
it's it's a lot it's a heavy regulation
business but there's there's a huge
market for again it's it's parallel
economy stuff and like why are we giving
money to companies that hate us and
they're taking our hard-earned money and
they're putting it into causes that we
hate and so I just I sitting there and
see like and look there's we can't do
that with every single product look my
house is filled with products made in
communist China I don't want that but
there's a lot not a lot of options there
is now an option for an americanmade
beer an American-owned beer as well
let's go all right man thanks for
hanging out we got Lukowski as well is
it real women or modern women in the
calendar it is real underlined real
underlined women of America I'm looking
forward be very clear I said that well
who some of the names people would know
like Riley Gaines Riley Gaines Kim kic
Dana lash Ashley stair Ashley stclair uh
Josie the redhead of libertarian wow you
got everybody yeah we got got all kinds
of people in here so you have to check
it out at conservative dad.com cool my
name is lowski sorry go ahead oh no I
was just saying 10% from the calendar is
going to the rileigh gain Center which
is fighting men and women sports I think
we've raised about 20,000 for so far and
hopefully way more by the time we're
we're done selling that's awesome my
name is Lukowski of youtube.com wear
change and a couple months ago we made
satirical Tucker Carlson for president
t-shirts when he was fired from Fox News
and now there talks of him potentially
becoming a vice president I think that's
a great idea if you agree you could get
the shirt on the best political
shirts.com and support my Independent
Media organization as of course this
company started because YouTube
demonetized me I also have we are
change. shop and I think us going into
the business World entrepreneurial world
is where we need to go so thank you for
doing what you're doing thank you Tim
for doing what you're doing and Ian
what's up with you man you're welcome
for me doing one hey Luke uh did you
guys show this calendar yet you want me
to show this this is Riley gain on cover
is beautiful it's beautiful cover look
at that she's like not even photosho she
looks like photoshopping real life love
it that's awesome and I love Seth that
you said how you explain that we need to
focus on buying products that are made
in America but are also America owned
because annh Heiser bush is it's in St
Louis but it's a Belgian owned company
now yeah it was sold to inbev and
there's people that have contacted me
and be like yo I work for anheiser Bush
I work in America it's an American thing
and it's like yeah but it's not own it's
a it's a foreign company now even though
it's Made In America which means a
portion of all those sales is going to
Europe correct now one thing I would
like to say on the show real quick if
you are a chain director and you have a
chain director experience in the
beverage industry specifically alcohol
but the beverage industry in general we
are looking for someone and that is a
hard job to find because you have to
have someone that has experience in that
so I'm going to take this moment to like
you know ask that if you're a chain
director have that experience reach out
to me on Twitter at Seth weathers if you
have no experience in that I love you
but don't apply oh you're about to show
look at this I want to give I want to
give a shout out to this guy too this uh
this is zenjoy it's really good yeah we
met this guy in the street we were just
in a store and we were like I was
inspired we went to a store earlier
today and some guy recognized me and
asked me if I'd be interested in trying
some of his products he asked me if I
like tea I said I did and he said that
he sells what he makes is the opposite
the opposite of an energy drink a
relaxation drink called zenjoy small
business he's he's he pulls up in his
van he pops up in the back and he's like
I got some drinks will you try them like
bro I'll buy a case off you right now uh
I'm inspired by the entrepreneurial
attitude he says I'm hoping to build
this business and make it work but he
said something really great he said you
get all these energy drinks and he's
like I'd like to give these to
Firefighters First Responders police
officers cuz I know it's a stressful job
I hope it helps helps make them relax
and I was like bro you just sold me
right away so uh shout out to zenjoy and
uh he was super excited I was like bro
we'll shout you out this is awesome I
really appreciate great it's got ashwag
Ganda lemon balm and uh lenine and this
got like a black tea uh a little bit of
sugar and I I knew I liked it I took a
sip and I was like oh that's pretty good
and then I took without even realizing
it three more sips and I was like I
guess I really like it it's really great
it's really powerful but people should
not take it more than uh for for one
month I sell ashal Gonda 2 and I tell
people hey only take it for one month
don't take it for more than that uh
because of the scientific kind of uh
benefits and even um negatives that you
could get from it but it's a powerful
beautiful thing I sell it I love it
what's the website where people buy
yours we are change. shop but I don't
want to mine I want to shout out this
guy for for meeting Joy I like it just
being an entrepreneur and you know
seeing that dude pop up in the back of
his van and be like I'm hoping to you
know he's got a bunch he's got he's saw
a bunch of Loc I was like dude he was
hustling working himself as the CEO
going store to store to store so you got
to you got to respect it say shake well
I didn't shake it well but it Stills
delicious all right we got sege pressing
buttons yo uh yeah happy to see you here
Seth always a pleasure great to be back
I love your hat today we're in the ultra
right hat today yeah uh yeah let's get
to it Tim let's get it we got big news
ladies and gentlemen house votes to
formalize Republican impeachment inquiry
into Joe Biden I love how they have to
put Republican but technically it would
just be the Impe inquiry because the
Republicans have the majority the 221 to
212 party line vote opens a door for the
GOP to get more evidence about schemes
that have been that have seen the Biden
family get millions from countries
including China Ukraine Romania and the
bidens will will now have more of their
bank records mortgage details emails
text messages and mobile phone subpoena
along with anything else Congress wants
to see since the start of 23 Republicans
have been investigating Joe Biden over
his alleged connections to his son
Hunter's extremely lucrative
multi-million dollar influence pedling
scheme spanning decades with a formal
impeachment inquiry vote Republicans say
the White House can no longer Stonewall
them for request of documents and
depositions but top GOP leaders have
argued it wasn't necessary you do not
need a full vote of the house to do an
impeachment inquiry to do the
investigation that we're
constitutionally obligated to do GOP
whip Tom emmer told the Daily Mail IE
the vote but this is basically showing
there the the Republican party is
investigating Joe Biden it is formalized
they will have more powers and this is
step one this is what we we kept arguing
about they they would say like oh we're
we're going to uh we the impeachment in
Korea is coming it's coming we're like
yeah yeah and so the story was Kevin
McCarthy vows to uh have hold inquiry
into whether or not there should be a
vote on whether or not there should be
an impeachment inquiry and now Kevin
McCarthy's gone and now they've finally
formalized the impeachment inquiry
process this so I'll explain it in
non-political terms they have formally
launched a criminal investigation into
Joe Biden should they find a
preponderance of evidence they will
launch an impeachment also known as an
indictment or other words an indictment
the indictment leads to a trial and
should Biden be convicted that will be
the conviction in impeachment and the
removal from office I don't believe
that's very likely but this is the
criminal investigation phase of Joe
Biden's impeachment process I kind of
I've been sensing it man when Hunter
stood in front of was that this morning
or yesterday morning I think and just
refused to answer he he made a statement
then left and then did he leave like a b
he avoided his trial and I will probably
have a different opinion on that and I I
hate when Republicans put me in these
kind of positions of like I'm going to
have to defend Hunter Biden I'm not
defending him but here he wanted it to
be a public hearing from the way I hear
it you know what if Congress ever hauled
my butt in for anything like I want this
public like I just really like the
idea that for whatever reason they
didn't want to have I understand he's
going to Grand stand he's going to try
to make his point his views Etc but I
think it's fair to say yeah if I'm going
to be hauled in front of Cong Congress I
want it to be public I think that's a
fair statement I think that's a fair St
so why can't the Republicans say hey you
know what we can handle our own PR for
this we'll let him come in and say what
he wants to say and we'll refute it live
in front of the public I'll be open to
that but so he refused to do it unless
it's public and they're okay that
violates the rules you have to do not a
violation rules of violation what they
wanted it was this on top of Joe Biden
answering reporter's questions they're
like hey what's up with these business
dealings he's like you're lying you're
all lying and I'm like oh this is coming
man I just saw this this feels like it's
been coming they don't I don't think
anybody wants him to run as president he
won't let go I do I want him to run yeah
I'm all for Biden I I made Biden fedman
t-shirts I want fedman to be the VP on
on his ticket there because you know
obviously obiously it's a no but but but
not just that but because clearly he is
sticking to his guns he's saying I'm not
leaving even a couple weeks ago the
Speaker of the House said oh you know
there's nothing to really investigate
Joe Biden on and a lot of people were
saying well that's kind of strategic
right before this election cycle because
if we do impeach him if we do
investigate him this might potenti make
him not be able to run for the
presidency of the United States is this
going to be something that's going to be
happening now with this impeachment why
is there a sudden shift in in Congress
they have no spine there's no shift it's
a different excuse they just don't have
to go through with it no they need to
get rid of Biden this is not good for
Trump right oh yeah right the question
is how do you remove Joe Biden if Joe
Biden gets
impeached convicted and then they
criminally and then they they criminally
convict Donald Trump they will say we've
been impartial the whole time Joe Biden
went down for corruption and Donald
Trump and now we have Nome V de santis
and you know who wins that election
Nome unfortunately you correct why do
you think it's you think it's just gonna
be Des santis well excuse me well I mean
he's he's
he's even worse I mean I'm being hopeful
when new some Nikki Haley who do you
vote for no I vote fory over
that wal or I mean well I'm not saying I
would enjoy that vote why do you be such
a terrible option I mean that's usually
the election cycle in America turd
sandwich or but I was
excited the worst of those is that I
think Nikki Haley would get us into war
with Iran whereas Gavin would capitulate
to the financial he get us in a war with
ourselves he would spark a civil war
from from my perspective but you think
vi just the media hates him too much
they're going to they're going to try
and stop him and make him look like a
bad guy I think Trump would
automatically and say hey VC should be
the president because VI is the only
person who said that he would pardon
Donald Trump if he would become the
president of the United States and
didn't hesitate to say that so I think
Vivic might have a path here with how
tulous and crazy the situation could get
here as of course if I'm Donald Trump
I'm I'm rooting for a Vivic if I can't
run and I I can't be the president of
the United States Tucker too yeah Tucker
could be VP well Tucker always made
these kind of statements saying you know
I don't want to be a politician but it's
always the polit the people who don't
want to be politicians that should be
the politicians so he always has a way
of kind of saying these things and
making people understand that there is a
sense of Duty and responsibility when it
comes to public office that he
understands even though he says he
doesn't want it but then he describes
people who don't want it as the people
who should be there so uh duplic
messages and this is why Tucker Carlson
2024 this I got the T-shirt I'm going to
sell a lot more of them if this if this
becomes the case but it's not just about
the t-shirt it's about the future of
this country that uh is uh in a very
dangerous situation right now it's
really funny because uh okay so if Joe
Biden gets impeached Kam Harris will
take over but she will likely say I'm
not going to run she's probably going
pro in the event Biden is impeached and
convicted removed Kamala becomes acting
president and says I'm not going to
spend the one year I have to help the
American people campaigning and then
she's going to say you know the
Democrats will have a process to
determine who the nominee shall be and I
will I will protect the office and this
country for the remainder of this term
then she bows out then Nome steps in and
it's going to be you know Nome and and
who do you think his VP is going to be
Lucifer I don't know Satan what if what
if it's Nome Haley versus like DeSantis
Nome Michelle Obama maybe right it would
be interesting to see people from
multiple parties come together to one
party here's here's right that's the
same party Newsome and Hal that would
count Chris Christie and this is why uh
uh I think it's really really funny a
year or two ago we're all like impeach
this this what what the bidens have been
doing for years and now we're close to
elction like no no no no no no no there
the people I think call your congressman
and say no impeachment we want Biden to
stay I kind of I feel like if Biden
stays he'll win again just because of
the way the system works uh
unfortunately I don't like the way the
media can Propel people to vote a
certain way just by convincing them it's
very very very very powerful hey ion
musk is actually had a huge change on
what the next election will be based on
Twitter now X so they were able to
censor so much that just never could
make it through on the old Twitter that
won't happen this time and I've I've
said this multiple times like is an
example our Beer Company would not exist
without Elon Musk reason being we would
never have been allowed to go viral to
the level that we did anywhere other
than an Elon mus owned Twitter uh you
can look at what we did on other
platforms hardly anything yet on Twitter
we have almost 50 million views yet
magically on Facebook Instagram all
those places you maybe get a million if
even that if we had real free speech if
we had the ability to actually talk to
each other without algorithms and
censorship efforts Donald Trump would
have been the president of the United
States right now he would have not lost
but it's because of the censorship it's
because of the manipulation because of
the fortifying why essentially Joe Biden
was allowed to be where he is right now
because he was able to censor stories
like the hunter Biden laptop story from
the general public which we know played
a major impact on the election so free
speech is important here and I think
this is why there're so many attacks on
Elon Musk trying to destroy him trying
to take down Twitter because if you take
down Twitter you could essentially
fortify all the elections in the future
did you see NBC news's breaking story I
I just love this they wrote an article
and it said the Tesla's new Cyber truck
weighing it at 6,800 lb could be lethal
in collisions with pedestrians and
smaller cars experts Warn and I was like
Wow Wow don't get hit by truck breaking
news this is how much they're going
after Elon Musk they actually wrote that
news story
incred to about a recall about the the
sof again oh no real quick this piss me
off it's been reported everywhere Tesla
recalls all vehicles to fix dangerous
thing what it really means is Tesla
issues software update you won't even
notice I was about say you don't even
have to go in anywhere to get it from
what I understand it's just a download
through your
system but they're calling it a recall
oh yeah no it's it's it's it's complete
BS you're you're going to wake up and
your app's going going to be like
updated you're go oh whatever I want to
do a soft correction of what you said
about Joe Biden censoring the hunter
thing cuz I don't think I don't think
there's evidence that he did it directly
it was just that I think there's
evidence the FBI was involved spoke then
uh but it was the intell
agenc this but you might consider that
he he was I don't know if he was
directly involved but it was his son was
was the one that was under investigation
you going to vote for Trump
Luke um maybe possibly I still want to
be one I still who you going vote for
who the hell are you going to vote for
have this conv
manbear Pig there's you go that over
trump it it depends uh it depends who's
running I I I I do think obviously if if
if I have to
Trump okay you you don't have to vote
for anybody I'm I'm explaining it I I I
had a friend hit me up and he's like are
you seriously he's like a liberal guy
he's like are you seriously considering
voting for Donald Trump and I was like
considering I was like I'm voting for
Donald Trump and he was like why and and
he said all all of the bad things Trump
has done and I'm like I'm not even going
to argue with you anything you think
that that Trump will do to this country
that is bad then I think America
deserves based on its foreign policy and
Trump's first uh term was no new Wars
and that is what we must do so my view
is this first of all economy was great I
think Trump actually did a pretty good
job considering the weights tied to his
ankles he did some bad things but I
think it was an overall net positive if
the reality was this country will be in
hard times but no new Wars take it
but the reality is it's going to be
better with no new Wars so my argument
to the liberal guy is oh you agree with
the military-- industrial complex you
want to vote for Biden and have more war
in the Middle East South America Europe
no okay vote for Trump I I just I hope
he can keep his cool that's a big part
he kept his cool his whole term there
was literally no new war he used he used
to tweet a lot about like those radical
he would like incite the left right
parad no but that's what kept us out of
some of it's going to depend who who his
VP is going to be as well because if
it's if it's someone that's going to be
like another mik Pence if he's going to
be surrounding himself with Henry
Kissinger again and John Bolton again
and all these other
horrible if it's Nikki Haley yeah I
wasn't kiss if it's Nikki Haley would
you not vote for him you would vote for
Biden or Niki Haley or Biden no no no if
Trump chose Nikki Haley which I think
would be horrific as his VP would you
vote for why vote why vote at all then
that's why I'm asking okay look look I I
will promise you this that's a vote for
if Donald Trump draws a gigantic
pentagram on the on the ground in a
black robe and summons the zombie corpse
of Kissinger I also will not vote for
him hey they do that type of stuff they
they do they do that type of stuff with
Marina brovich okay and and like that
that's on record that's fact there's
videos they summon they summon demons
through writing with their bodily fluids
wall okay what are you I like that one
you you just heard about this to you
just heard about this all the bodily
fluids blood spit urine okay okay
right we broke the story Spirit cooking
story
on that story yes and anyway I was
making a joke I agree with the
criticisms of uh Trump with Kissinger
and uh Sheldon addon and John Bolton and
all that was bad no new Wars I think you
made a good point the VP is very
important right now very very important
because it's Tucker if it's RFK if it's
Vivic okay you got me but if it's Nikki
Haley Chris Christie or or another Mike
Pence or another neocon I'm like what's
the point of even voting then you just
got to hope that Trump
survives again I'm not here I'm not here
to vote I think the idea is election
Cycles everyone says oh I got to vote
for this guy no the ideas matter the
most so the people that push the ideas
the most the people who start the
conversations the most I think have a
bigger impact than the actual person
that is selected or elected to be the
become the next president of the United
States so so this is where I'm looking
at where are the conversations where are
the debates where can we push the overt
window to a position where we could
actually make people understand the real
reality of the situation that we're
under right now that's a really good
point man because you saw the way
Trump's generals just ignored his orders
and play shell games like if we don't
acknowledge the situation we're in now
it's going to be too late I know
everyone says that election cycle after
election cycle but I do think we're at a
pivotal Point absolutely I want I want
to jump to this next
story Hunter Biden defies GOP
Congressional subpoena quote he just got
into more trouble and the GOP is vowing
to initiate contempt proceedings after
Hunter Biden flouts this subpoena to
closed door testimony uh we did talk
about it a little bit already but what
do you think's going to happen you think
they're they're going to give him the
Steve Bannon treatment he's going to go
to jail because he defi a congressional
subpoena well no because the Democrats
are in charge and they run the
intelligence agencies and the Department
of Justice and their attorney generals
and of course Justice is skewed on a
political perspective but this could
also this could also be a political
pressure put on Biden saying hey we're
going to put your son in jail unless you
bow out of this election cycle by the
intellig intelligence State we we are
going to go after your son yeah but I
wonder can the can the White House
pardon on contempt charges when it when
it's initiated by the Legislative Branch
because I would imagine checks and
balances are supposed to prevent this if
if Congress holds you in contempt the
the federal the federal uh the executive
branch should not be able to intervene
right I'm not an attorney I think we
need one on this one I know that's
that's interesting because Congress is
saying do this or else if the executive
branch was able to come in and say no
they don't have to that would give the
executive branch substantial power over
the legislative I'm kind of with you
Seth from what you said earlier that I I
don't I think he maybe should have a
public hearing like his testimony in
public why why not man like it's not a
that's not a partisan thing it's just
like why are they why are they trying to
get it's not family friendly I don't
care they're probably discussing a lot
of things that would be censored
automatically on YouTube that we can't
even discuss here that he particularly
uh you know uh played a major role in
spending millions of dollars on you know
I look look like the dude from eve6 had
a great tweet and I'm like this guy's
like a lefty and so when Hunter Biden
gives the speech where he's like talking
about how he's not going to submit to
this even leftists are saying like
you've taken way too many photographs
with crack and hookers for anyone to
defend you at this point yeah man he's a
deviant that's for sure and that's the
that's that's that's the least that's
the least B bad thing I would like to
ask him right how he admirable for for a
lot of other people I think like
$800,000 on on $688,000 reportedly on
they're called know there was more it's
said various women over what period of
Time how many women how many times a day
like I want to know some numbers
apparently he wants you to know the
numbers too he's proud maybe he's proud
of it he's like yo if I'm going down I
want everyone to know my life yeah I'm
just kind of curious at this point how
long over how many years did he spend
that 688,000 four maybe or something but
but hold on hold on let's be let's be
real $680,000 on various women could
also mean he bought them dinners you
know he flew them on private jets
staying in hotels on islands and things
I'm not I'm not sure the reporting was
that he literally gave that much to
women for their company if you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah again this is
something we should get to in the
inquiry I'd like to imagine I mean I
mean let's just think about this life I
mean the dude is basically living in a a
just a a swamp of debauchery and I feel
bad for him it's like a cursed existence
where he's just covered in slime yeah
literally 700 granders dude yeah these
women have some slime diseases that's
that's on the
record that's not cash imagine what the
cash purchases here okay that that's
yeah cuz there's a lot of withdrawals
but like I'm I'm like from the videos
the things I've seen out of Hunter Biden
these were not really highend women so I
feel like this is a lot of different
women like it's not like he's getting
the you know right cuz they're talking
30 40 bucks
yeah he's got he's got to go a long way
to get up to 700k that's what I'm saying
like another 40 oh man under a bridge I
mean dude the videos aren't there like
videos where he's got like three women
yeah but they everything I've seen they
look rough these women could not be
charging a lot that's what I'm I agree
so we're talking like he's finding like
three or four women and giveing them
each like a 100 bucks to get to 700k is
a lot maybe just gives Aon H by so that
you one special girl he gave like 300
know right it's like one woman to Maui H
her treated her right for 6 months yeah
Dr her around and wasn't there a movie
about this what was that famous movie no
no no Pretty Woman yes yeah yeah yeah
apparently it was a very dark movie in
the beginning and that changed Julia
Roberts was saying I didn't know oh it
was supposed to be like really nasty
yeah apparently I mean the movie is
fairly bad yeah I don't know how women
treat like oh such a love tale I'm like
it's kind of she's a hooker
I know like she was literally a street
corner hooker and every such a sweet
tale it's funny how this story with
Hunter has these dichotomies like he's
like my father my parents took such good
like I feel sad for a human going
through this crappy life with a super
famous dad that didn't give him enough
attention and just bought him out of
trouble but at the same time like bro if
you used your dad's money and he was had
like cycling political influence that's
like fullon political we cannot tolerate
that in our government anymore we've got
to we're at the age of we're to the age
of Aquarius but the age of openness like
the the apocalypse is upon us you you
can't and Well that took a dark turn
yeah apocalypse meaning the Great
Awakening the great um revealment like
we're in this age of revealment where
like I I just I don't I don't hate this
guy it's just like what can we let it
stand can we pardon him and just be like
yo what you did can never happen again
but we're not going to destroy ourselves
and you okay hold on there minute the
the drugs and the hookers is a hunter
you need some help I'm I'm hearing that
you're getting clean correct this is
good for you now let's move on to the
bribery the influence pedaling the
funneling money to your dad yeah cuz he
and Joe they could have got to the the
checks for the big guy the money the
shared bank accounts yeah yeah the the
Ukrainian oligarchs and business deals
that they had with with what was the oil
company again barisma barisma for
freak's sakes when you look at what's
happening in Ukraine holy cow there are
so many corrupted politicians there and
that whole case should have been
properly investigated Trump even just
trying to investigate it was impeached
for just trying to do that which was
absolutely crazy and now we're going to
finally investigate it what's up what's
going on here of course he was protected
before now he's not I think something's
up what if uh what if Hunter
flips oh wow like imagine imagine the
GOP and Trump they go to him and they
say not only are you going to be
pardoned you're going to be a hero just
tell everybody what happened with
barisma and then what if he comes out
and says we called my dad and asked them
to intervene on our behalf and then Joe
is just like oh crap because think about
it this gets Joe
out it gives Democrats an opportunity to
bring in
Nome yeah and I would I think a lot more
people be willing to par pardon Hunter
if he comes out clean it's safe so Joe
might say throw him into the bus this is
what we want then the Democrats bring in
Newsome you'll get pardoned people will
cheer for you for calling us out for
calling out the corruption or whatever
you're not going to be you're not going
to be perfect in the eyes but you you'll
have some Redemption Arc and then they
can bring in Nome and someone super
chated saying it's going to be Whitmer
Nome Whitmer yep I I saw that too and
then uh Biden will will pass on and then
Hunter Biden will become the next uh
politician that will probably become the
next president of the I I don't think
that'll happen but you gota it's like
man with uh uh Joe Biden is is is
clearly on the way out not all there
right now the play for a father to save
his son is to say to his son I mean do
you think Joe Biden has that much
dignity and self-respect to throw
himself off for his son I think I think
the root of corruption typically is
familial and friend friendly bonds the
reason why they engage in this level of
corruption is to is to enrich themselves
I I do believe Joe Biden cares about his
kids and I do believe he probably abused
his kids you know to a great degree so
maybe car isn't the right word but my
point is the Democrats want Nome in they
got to get Joe Biden out how do you do
it the inquiry is slow moving and right
now a bunch of people like wait a minute
wait a minute we don't want Joe Biden
impeached and convicted because we want
him to run against Trump Democrats need
to get somebody in what if Democrats
just make Joe Biden like climb a bunch
of really tall stairs a lot between now
and the election I think their odds
would be in their favor he won't make it
no because there's something that
happens to people at his age where with
with cellular regeneration operating at
such a low percentage stressing the body
actually does not improve him it
degrades him no I'm saying he's going to
Fallen oh right I thought you saying
work no no no working out we're P you're
right we're past workout yeah yeah
that's no no much darker thought there
the the the I'm I'm just saying maybe it
won't be Hunter Biden coming out and
being like I must tell the truth it
might be something like you know look
yeah we called my dad he did it and then
everyone goes we got him we got Joe
Biden the conservatives get to scream
and rub in the Democrats faces but then
they bring in Gavin Nome I think they're
too arrogant I don't think it'll happen
these people never think they're really
going to ever get caught because they
control everything they are the Deep
State they live in such a world of I
don't know where the word is but they're
they control it all when it comes to the
Deep State they have no fear of
themselves being thrown in jail for
protesting or anything else like that so
I don't think so I think I mean I I get
what you're saying but what you're
saying is almost a rational approach I
don't know that they're going to take a
rational approach I I I I think you may
be right but but consider this a basic
chess move no that's a smart move I
think I don't know that they're going to
make that smart move though Al I don't
think Hunter would do it because his
life would be forfeit if he he spoke out
opposite no this would save Hunter if
Hunter exposed the Deep State's plots in
Ukraine Hunter would not survive no no
no no no no you misunderstand the Deep
State wants Hunter to do it they need
Joe Biden out Joe Biden can't beat Trump
how do you get nuum in it's a it's a
great I don't know if it's a perfect
play but on the surface you get Hunter
Biden Joe Biden's son is saved Hey Joe
we want you out no I don't want to leave
okay well we're going to we're going to
save your son by having him come out and
and and provide evidence that removes
you from Office your son will be saved
you will be out Nome comes in Nome gives
us the war we want I guess if Hunter
could expose some of the dealings
without letting the American people know
that they kind of got us into the war
and you like their corruption with
parisma like accelerated this he will
only reveal what the Deep State wants
him to in order to remove Joe Biden and
get Nome Whitmer in I'm not saying it's
Absolut not the worst thing in the world
this guy's got a long life to live I
don't think he wants to die or like go
to jail or any of that but I also think
Joe and if you if you think Joe doesn't
have the Integrity to save his to
sacrifice himself for his son okay then
consider he doesn't have the
perspicacity or the cognitive faculties
to understand what's happening at all
that's close to reality Hunter going to
be like my dad did it that's Joe bid and
uh he's he's crooked what can I say I'm
sorry American
Joe's response
is and that's it yeah Hunter has to go
to the CIA and say hey I'll do whatever
you guys want me to do we'll take out my
dad I'm really pissed at my dad is of
course A lot of people are also kind of
theorizing that a lot of what came out
through the laptop was kind of a
deliberate release since there are many
serious accusations against uh Joe Biden
hurting his children especially with the
hunter uh especially with the the Biden
diary that the FBI was after specific Al
even raiding the home of James O'Keefe
after that uh they kind of verified the
findings in which essentially detailed
some very disturbing events that
unfolded between uh Joe Biden and his uh
younger daughter so a lot of people are
saying maybe Hunter Biden released all
the details of his laptop maybe he
deliberately tried to get it publicized
in order to bring down his father as a
part of a retribution uh plan to finally
get some justice against him for
possibly hurting and abusing at the very
least like subconsciously I can see that
happening cuz like I've I've been really
high in my life and like had such
self-hatred that I would allow that
stuff came out that was like true that I
wouldn't normally say if I was sober but
but listen Bill Clinton said House of
Cards is 99% accurate for a reason and
when you watch that TV series uh you see
a lot of backstabbing you see people
just you know take each other out
politically in so many uh dastardly uh
ways and you see a lot of really
Sinister activities of people just
screwing each other over all the time
that's Washington DC so I think
everything is at play here because the
establishment is going to lose they are
going to lose their main puppet their
main frontman their main skin suit that
allows them to implement whatever
policies they want on the American
people no matter how unpopular they're
able to do it through Joe Biden why
would they give it up if they're going
to lose this upcoming election no matter
what they need something else that is
going to be happening behind the scenes
that we might not even know of that's
happening right now we have to just make
sure that we don't trash ourselves the
Americans the in the meantime while this
is happening so that the global banking
takes this country over that would be
the worst possible outcome like the
Trump Biden all this Republican Democrat
crap has to be put aside for American
Unity com coming in 2020 it's so
important looks let's let's jump to this
uh cultural segment ladies and gentlemen
Matt Walsh has taken off the glove and
struck me with it in his latest episode
he said Tim pool is wrong how dare you
no I'm just kidding uh I respect Matt
Walsh's opinion I love the debate and
Matt Walsh says the budlight boycott
continues in a tweet he he also did have
a a decently long segment on his show
where he addressed Dana White Tucker
cross and Kid Rock as well as myself and
uh it was respectful and it was uh
intelligent and I agree with a lot of a
lot of what he said and I don't
completely disagree with the idea of
continuing the boycott all I'm saying is
we need to consider our next moves if
the plan is a boycott but let me read
first what Matt Walsh says he tweets the
Bud Light boycott is one of the is is
the one time in modern history when
conservatives have staged an effective
boycott against a major corporate brand
if we back away from this Victory now it
will show that we've learned nothing and
don't want to win not going to happen
boycott continues this shouldn't even be
a conversation budlight is a brand owned
by a foreign conglomerate that tried to
push trans ideology and is now paying
the price there is absolutely no
legitimate reason to back away or let
off the gas they deserve everything
that's happened to them well as the
debate continues I'd like to first ask
our local beeran who's here to who
actually runs a beer company and is
challenged budlight directly your
thoughts on on the boycott and what do
you think we should do I think I've been
saying this from the beginning of this
whole thing is like this is the one time
I've seen conservatives follow through
with the actual boycott and the past we
be like oh we're skipping an NFL game
we're skipping a baseball game we
skipped two or three games everybody's
back in the stands this is the one time
we've done it I think the only way to be
taken seriously in the future is to
cause permanent economic harm to a major
corporation and I think that this is our
opportunity we may fail in the end I
understand what you're saying but this
is our shot to do it and so you have to
stick to it so what's so your your
argument is double down no one should
ever buy budlight again no matter what I
mean it seems a little bias coming from
me I'm not going to lie but yeah what
would be the purpose of doing so at this
point in your life so so my argument
is 30% loss and sales year-over-year up
to date and budlight has just put 100
105 million per year into
UFC now is the opportunity to steal the
narrative with what Shan Strickland said
on Twitter which can't be said on Sean
Strickland's never going to we're never
going to be able to steal the narrative
maybe within a circle narrative is
stolen when every conservative repeats
what but they'll never do it most
conservatives are starts with a P ends
with the Y they don't follow through and
do these things it's never going to
happen so that Sean Strickland will and
that's why we're sitting there talking
about Sean Strickland so consider now
where where we go from here if
conservatives will do nothing else what
what what happens
tomorrow I think they can continue with
their boycott no no no what what does
budlight do
tomorrow I mean there's a lot of things
they're doing and they're going to do
they're putting more money into
different ones of different brands
within their entity they're doing things
like that it's where they've pulled back
a lot of the spending on their
advertising for budlight itself and
they've redirected those F you think
budlight will
apologize no yeah I think an apology
would do more damage at this point no no
I don't think it would I think we give
everyone the okay I I I think an apology
would actually boost their sales I think
it would remind people what they did and
that would enhance the boycot people
haven't forgotten so here's here here's
here's the paths we have before us if
everybody wants to continue the boycott
totally on board we need people to
Double Down yes Shan Strickland opened
the door for you I'm not saying what he
does as a UFC champion is the he's a
it's the tip of the spear but you you're
requiring the rest of the spear for this
to work he made some statements on
Twitter directly under the banner of
budlight shockingly offensive to the
woke left and budlight said nothing the
attack opportunity right now would be
for conservatives to hold up a Bud Light
repeat the words of Shan Strickland and
say wow thanks budlight for sponsoring
UFC and Shawn we completely agree with
your message and then read off his
tweets the conservatives aren't going to
do it then if they W conservatives come
up to me in the gym and Whisper like hey
I really support what you're doing I
like it I'm like why are we Whispering
they're scared you think they're going
to go say the kind of stuff
that my argument was at this point with
Dana White Kid Rock coming out and being
like we've done we've done the damage
let's claim the victory I'm like if this
is where conservatives stop and they
won't take another step forward then the
best thing we can do right now is say we
won I'm not saying buy budlight ever
again fine don't I'm saying claim the
narrative Victory say we've done
everything we wanted to do budlight
learned their lesson and let be lesson
to each and every one of you you've lost
30% good luck in the future but our
message stands I don't think anyone's
ever going to see that as a victory if
they all go back the D I'm not saying go
back I'm saying at this point you have
claim a victory start claiming it today
I'm with you there say we we've won
because it's down You' have to say we
did everything we wanted to do because
if no one goes one step further and UFC
Dana White goes on Tucker Carlson and
says Bud light's great you should buy
Bud Light and no one calls out Dana
White for this and UFC is unscathed then
the narrative is the boycott is over if
the boycott is over Kid Rock said so and
Dana White basically like he's not I
think those are two I think those are
two people I've been bars restaurants
stores Etc the average person is not my
my point is how do you get Coca-Cola how
do you get Disney how do you get all
these corporations to be scared to not
do the same thing you have to look at
the fact that bud white will still be
down 25% or 22% 24% whatever it is 3
years from now and this require that
leaves a lot of fear I think it will be
there's look I've talked to Distributors
and stuff there is there is 20 to 23 or
something like this per that will never
go back to buying Bud Light they bought
it all their
lives from now they'll move it around
that's fine but they will not be able to
show within the Bud white brand because
they're treated like different entities
they're not going be able to show like
oh it came back it's 22 to whatever it
is percent in 10 years from now they
won't have that leaves a lasting impact
on a corporation that goes like remember
what happened to them that's bad I I I
do think this will have a lasting impact
there's a famous case where uh in
McDonald's in the UK a couple act the
reason why corporations don't Sue
activists a couple of activists were
stand outside outside of McDonald's I
think it was McDonald's petitioning
saying hey McDonald's is bad they do
this thing McDonald's sued them
McDonald's I believe was it's an old
story I could be wrong but I believe
McDonald's was right these activists
were defaming them and they won and then
they lost something like a billion
dollars in market cap because they
looked like bullies attacking some
little old ladies so it was really
really bad for them what ends up
happening is when people challenge
Brands the brands usually shut up and
back off well if if oh if you want to
double down if if if the next move is to
twist the knife so to speak the the
proverbial knife you want to boycott all
of the anheiser Bush Brands which are
Michelob Rolling Rock Bush natural
Johnny and then the question is do you
want to boycott the brands of the parent
company a the the Belgian company AB
ined which are Corona hog Garden if
everyone wants to boyot every beer brand
but conservative dad's Ultra right beer
I'm with you I don't think it will
actually happen though so that's why I
was specific about with Bud Light I was
like this is the you got to Target in on
that I said that early and because
people start saying well here's the list
of all the stuff the Nerds are pulling
out their list of all the beer brands
you can't I'm like yeah you got to focus
it's like six to eight% the the the the
uh um ex what's what's the right word
the the the impact on external Brands is
around 6 to 8% we've seen aner Bush
across the board suffering because of
this because some people are Die Hard
the only point I'm trying to make right
now what's the next move silence is not
an option I think what needs to happen
is by all means say we boycotted it
we'll boycott it forever but it's done
we're moving on we've won this is this
is your fault Bud Light and it'll happen
to any other company that does so next
but you need to say this is the extent
to which we wanted right that's fine TOA
I get what you're saying there that's
fine to claim the victory for there but
you can't say it's okay to come back now
like Dana White can tell people to do
keg stands in their in their day call I
agree and I I like probably a ton of
what Dana White does not a big fan of
that cuz you know what who knows what
you could get me to say for 105 million
so Dana there you go good for I think
we're also in a position of power right
now and in in a situation like like this
they understand the the leftist yuppies
are not going to be drinking their beer
right so why not try to get more out of
this and I think we can get kind of more
out of this by by saying hey uh we can't
just be plated with a little bit of
money we want real cultural differences
we want investment we want you guys to
actually stand behind your word not just
advertise we want Dan White can be
plated by a little bit of money or maybe
a lot of money per se oh then you know
what if they want to give 105 million to
the rally gain Center to Def to fight
men and women's sports then I say big
victory how much how much are you going
to give to the Republicans how much are
you going to give to the Republican
Presidential Nomine in the culture War
we just won a huge battle the troops are
broken they are fleeing now is our
opportunity to to do the route but
they're sending a rear guard attachment
to delay our route that's the 100
million to Dana White as the rear guard
defense now we can bypass that defense
and go for the route by boycotting all
of these beers from this company that's
it that's the total destroy destroy Dy
do you want respect I respect the the
the analogy but I think it's a little
off the giving money is they've been
routed their command their their field
commanders raised the white flag and
said we're willing to seed 10% of the
battlefield if you stop and then one of
the commanders on our side came out and
said everyone let's take it and we're
done and many many all the troops are
screaming no if that's the case you
cannot just sit there screaming no
something else must be done the
opportunity now I think is going to be
uh the figurative knife twisting of
taking a can of budlight and reading off
Shan Strickland's tweets and forcing
budlight to either issue a denouncement
or an apology like I look all I can say
is this people really need to go go read
what Sean Strickland said to understand
what I'm saying I can't I cannot say I I
cannot say it on YouTube I know but it's
just a tweet is going to it doesn't have
that kind of influence you there was a
guy who lost his sponsors in NASCAR
because his dad used a racial slur in
the 80s that's where we were where we
are now is that Bud Light shut up up
when Sean Strickland made a statement so
so so strong we I can't I can't repeat
it on YouTube that and no and nothing
nothing happened so This Is Us storing
the battle really reached the average
person knowing about that this is why
saying people need to take his tweets
and and force budlight to either support
or denounce what he said budlight
advertisement with with him with the dag
saying it to the world I don't
understand why guys AR interested in
boycotting sponsored by Bud Light he
said brought to you by budlight like Bud
light's just a name of the of many
things that the company why not boycott
the entire company all these all these
you correct no one's doing it look look
how hard it was to get conservatives to
boycott anything past a couple days and
now you're going to tell them they got
to read a list of all their favorite
alcohol Brands and they can't get a
Corona on the beach anymore they can't
handle it we can't get Republicans to
show up and freaking vote in a freaking
primary and you're asking we give her
their favorite beer we went we went to
Charleston West Virginia it's about 5
hours from here we went to Marty gr
Casino where several people recognized
me and they were big fans and they were
all holding Bud
Lights and I laughed and I was like you
guys drinking Bud Light and they're like
well I don't
know my point this is the funny thing
right we launched uh uh we relaunched
cnr.com and I got a Super Chat the other
day from someone like what is this
you're just going to launch this thing
with no explanation and I was like bro
we've explained this like 20 times over
the past two months the issue is the
average person doesn't watch every
single episode of this show so how often
do we talk about Bud Light out of how
many segments we do we do five to six
segments per day on this show that get
spread out throughout the week and over
the past 6 months maybe like 20 of them
maybe 30 have been about but we haven't
talked about it in like 3 months exactly
I think that's when I was
here Austin we a lot of people don't
know this my view is simply we we want
every company to say I don't want to go
near Dylan mulvania and woke woke
sponsorship because I will lose lots and
lots of money how so then that that
would mean we need to say we did it we
won B Bud Light bye-bye and then we just
move on from
it that might be the right move I don't
hate ab and Bev I mean they made a
stupid Choice by marketing their beer to
kids with through through Dylan malany
and maybe that's all that needs to be
known like don't do it again it's a you
know I'm not huge fan of multinational
corporations but there's other ones like
the bank for international settlements
that I'd rather be boycotting yeah look
all major corporations I say all the
vast majority of major corporations hate
every single one of us in this room and
everything we stand for be give tons of
money to those causes that we hate go
ahead I think they hate
everybody I think most corporations are
looking at numbers and they're thinking
where do how how do we get sales my
concern is with a company as large as AB
inbev if sales among conservatives has
gone to zero they are not going to stop
trying to market the beer but it hasn't
gone to zero there are still a huge
percentage of conservatives that are
still drinking it absolutely as I
mentioned so they've got to right so
they they've got to have that fear of
okay we can't do anything else or it
will really be toast I don't believe
conservatives drink more beer than
liberals by the way I I I I I believe
that's true and that's why they screwed
up because budlight that that woman was
like the Frat bro image like well who do
you think's drinking your beer you know
what I mean if if a liberal is drinking
a beer it's going to be some weird small
batch you know craft brew out of
Williamsburg or something holla my my
concern is putting $100 million in UFC
is an opportunity to say spend money on
us give us your money someone super
chated Dana White just got $100 million
for free to make fun of budl yes we want
more of that how can we get more of that
what we don't want is for budlight to
eventually come April go we spent $100
million on this contract and it's it's
given us a zero return the shareholders
are angry and they're demanding we spend
the money elsewhere then they start
investing in who knows what the same
stuff they've always invested in Liberal
causes and and just advertising in
general so right so we want to stop that
we want more money to go to UFC I think
they're in a situation where they're
like their ship is sinking if their
sales are down 24 % that's like a
sinking brand agreed but the UFC has a
lot of money the UFC doesn't
need I don't care if they need it Bud
Light needs the UFC I'd rather Dana
White whether you love him or hate him
have the money over Dylan lania and so
the question is if their ship is sinking
Ian how do we convince them that we are
the ones who are going to make their
ship stay upright but they have to give
us the ship oh I just sync the ship just
let the ship syn yeah but it's not going
to well the Bud white brand will maybe
not the overall inbev I get what you're
saying there but will never go away the
fleet will not be necessarily but
forever be
a right and you agree they'll shift
their spending to other brands correct
and they're going to spend on those
other brands in the same direction they
they they've gone with
budlight no they they're not going to
they're not going to do a Dillan with
modella or or Corona whatever but
they'll do Pride events and stuff like
that so does Yingling AB absolutely yep
they do not conservative dad's Ultra
right beer I the only openly Pro lifee
and as conservative hot women let's just
say this let's just say this the only
option right now is the fight is over we
completely ignore Bud Light never buy
from them again the narrative drops we
don't we don't engage with it we just
support the parallel economy and go to
conservative dad.com and buy your Ultra
right beer that's the option I guess
because then it's not an issue of if
there's a boycott or not it's a we don't
care anymore have a nice day let them
spend the money where they want to spend
it and you spend your money on Parallel
economy products yeah Public Square
download Public Square I think that's a
good option because it does feel like
going balls to the wall against AB inbev
is like hostile like unnecessarily
hostile I kind of like a little bit of
unnecessary hostility in my life to be
honest though I mean kind way I've lived
the last I don't know man against a
multi I guess if you're going to go
against a multinational corporation the
a beer Corporation might be the right
one to Target hey fun story so this past
weekend we had our conservative d ultr
right uh anti-corporate Retreat up in
Gatlinburg in the Smoky Mountains and
there was evidently a frat party going
on on each side of the cabin that we
were all in we had everyone with our
company this huge cabin there's this
frat party going on somehow they ended
up with a ton of ultra right beer at
these frat parties I went over there for
a little while they were dumping the
other beers they had no Bud Light I'd
like to play it was a fun experience I'm
waiting for those photos and videos to
come out I'll explain it all once it
does but it was a good time had by all
well I told them the other night my
victory condition would be to see your
company buy Bud buy that brand I like
this idea I think we're a few billions
short but I like the concept maybe yeah
how about we uh let's jump to this next
story ladies and gentlemen I give you
predictive programming hey who wants to
read those words I don't want to say it
out loud it says are you are you ready
everybody Civil War what is this
official trailer HD a24 the new movie
that is coming out in 2024 starring
Kirsten Dunst and many others is a movie
about 19 states seceding from the Union
a civil war erupting and the the Western
forces of California and Texas are
attacking their way through the US to
make their way to DC for some reason we
don't know the exact story all I know is
the premise based on the trailer sounds
completely ridiculous Texas and
California will never unite there would
not be a Civil War in which those two
states are unified because there are
states between them however they do
mention 19 states seceded in the trailer
so it could be that Texas and California
are part of the secession but the reason
it's called the Western force of Texas
and California is because they're the
two largest states in the seceding group
I don't understand why they would team
up at all I wonder what the story is
going to be but how is there a civil war
movie that they did not consult the
timcast crew on that's what I want to
know I feel like this should have been
like where they focused on I got a
feeling that they're not going to
involve foreign countries coming in and
like cuz what would happen in a real
Civil War is the CCP would be heavily
involved funding the war Chinese weapons
and planes and tank and the Russians and
the Iranians and the
syrians be a bit of a mess yeah it'll be
you know the Israeli government does
well especially and they would say would
be everywhere they would call it
California but it ain't California doing
the weapon same doing right now it would
be California and the Chinese would go
to them and they'd say we will give you
anything you want and we don't care what
happens afterwards and we will guarantee
your Independence after you win that's
what they'll tell them right right yes
yes yes they're saying just fight each
other just rip your country to shreds
that's it but a lot of people are
tweeting out predictive programming the
idea of predictive programming is that
powerful Elites government agents or
whatever condition the public through
mass media to encourage certain
behaviors in the event of a certain
circumstance so a simple a simple idea
would be let's say Civil War breaks out
nobody knows what it's going to look
like they want toate create an image of
what a civil war would look like before
it happens so that your behaviors will
be will fall into a certain Camp so uh
some ways to explain this right people
don't know what gunshots sound like
because they only hear guns for movies
that's not what gun sounds like every
time someone raises a gun in a movie The
Hammer clicks the gun which makes
literally no sense but because they're
and I don't believe that this is to
condition you it's because they're
trying to make you know the guns coming
but you'll always see in movies like
Indiana Jones for instance the new one
everybody raises guns to him and you
hear all the guns cocking like dude the
guns are already cocked round is already
chambered they're raising the gun there
would be no sound but for dramatic
effect so imagine it this way Civil War
breaks out everyone does a bunch of
random things you make a movie Civil War
breaks out and water is poisoned don't
drive Teslas a big component of the film
then what happens is this idea in
everyone's mind from watching a movie
that's probably wrong Civil War breaks
out everyone says better stay away from
Teslas that's the idea of predictive
programming I don't believe that's the
case you know I mean it's possible I
guess I think the reality is there have
been numerous articles numerous
statements from academics talking about
the possibility of a civil war there
have been numerous polls where people
say they want a civil war there have
been members of Congress calling for a
national divorce and some dude goes this
would be a great movie and he writes it
all down goes to an investor says let's
make this movie yeah there's many what
we find out was really behind the movie
he's like are you are you Bank rolling
this are you whole point for the past
seven years was that I can make you
doing theed program I see so we were we
were actually talking about this idea
yesterday I just posted the clip on my
uh Twitter at lukee are change uh
describing what I was uh talking about
when it comes to predictive programming
because I do believe that there are
actual incidences where this happened 24
and torture is one of them I mentioned
it yesterday we also saw the buildup to
the Iraq War have a lot of a lot of
popular media that went along with it
that essentially drove the American
people to believe that their lives were
in danger unless we fought the terrorist
over there and not over here so when you
look at the intelligence agencies and
their larger influence on pop culture on
media and entertainment this has this
has been something that they've been
influencing for many decades now a lot
of people bring up um a mocking bird a
lot of people bring up the the
commission hearings that were happen in
within Congress that exposed the
infiltration of the corporate media by
the intelligence agencies and if you're
at the Intel agencies what better way to
to get away with these larger ideas than
to kind of make people acques to them
through uh entertainment through
subconscious subliminal messaging in
films in movies I think this is why we
are seeing such racial division tones
almost in every form of entertainment
now I think it's also important to note
that right before the Ukrainian War
there was an extreme amount of Russian
propaganda we saw the corporate deep
State kind of media all in unison say
Russia Russia Russia hacked this
election and as we know none of that was
actually true but but the the Russian
Boogeyman was built up and now we are in
a proxy war with Russia using Ukraine as
essentially our larger kind of forces on
the ground to do the fighting for us and
sacrific their lives for this larger
neoconservative objective so I I do
believe Ive programming is true I do
believe it has been used there's a lot
of different ways to interpret it um a
lot of people will extrapolate whatever
little things they want to extrapolate
but I think it's clear Intel agencies
control the media the media does send
out particular messaging that does
actually happen you you you think
there's a strong possibility that
they're conditioning us to prepare for a
Civil War uh now as far as the whole
Civil War context again you can't really
say because it's more clear after the
fact so well real quick sorry to
interrupt but I just
it could be that they're trying to
condition people to not want Civil War
it's it's also impossible to figure
figure it out until after everything
happens because then you kind of put all
the pieces together uh especially when
it came to justifying torture in America
when it came to the the larger
entertainment entertainment series that
also had Intel influences that were
excusing torture by the Intel agencies
that's a clear example of them then us
finding out through Snowden and weaky
leaks that yes they were actually
torturing and trying to excuse it
through
media forms of entertainment so couple
years down the line if there's a civil
war we could say yes this was the kind
of predictive programming when the whole
Russia gate collusion stuff was
happening no one kind of foresaw hey
this is going to lead us to be in a kind
of proxy war with Russia now that we are
I think it's fair to say that that all
the stuff that we were hearing about
Russia being the boogeyman laid the
groundwork for us now being in this
proxy war so so this is how it works
we're going to know definitively later
down the line we can't know we can't
know now we can't tell now the reason
why they were trying to claim that Trump
was a Russian spy is because we were
supposed to be at war with Russia in
Ukraine in 2014 and 15 into 2016 or I
should just say 2017 because Obama
leaves everything freezes the escalation
on the on the Eastern front of Ukraine
sort of stopped Donald Trump gets in he
says I don't want war and then all of a
sudden the Ukrainian stuff froze I was
in Ukraine when this stuff was all
started I was there at the beginning of
the Euro Myan protests I I got to go and
actually see the statue that was toppled
fragments of of Lennon's head on the
ground and then uh Molotov cocktails I
ended up leaving around then it
escalated from there and the remaining
Vice C actually went to yanukovich's
house the former president who was
ousted and fled the country then Trump
gets elected everything stops and if
Hillary would have became president
there was a very high likelihood that
there would have been war with Russia
John McCain like L 100% yeah yeah John
McCain I mean it also depends on a lot
of different fact s China also plays a
role in this as well so does Iran so
does Saudi Arabia uh but but we have to
understand Lindsey Graham and John
McCain were in Ukraine during the mine
Revolution which was influenced by the
intelligence agencies that also helped
spur it on and help move Ukraine away
from the Russian influence towards the
more NATO Western influence they were
there on the ground saying yes we have
to fight the Russians we have to kick
out the Russians we have to have NATO
here inside of Ukraine all the way back
in 2014 and and they were banking the
military industrial complex the central
banks banksters the controllers were
banking on a larger conflict if Trump
wasn't elected and uh Trump still did
some things he did send lethal weapons
to Ukraine but his foreign policy
definitely wasn't as aggressive as
Hillary Clinton's would have been as
she's a total bloodthirsty Warhawk that
literally celebrates the torture and
death of individuals and cheers and
laughs about it I was thinking as you
were talking that came yeah we saw he
died that KFI that was so crazy she
laughed the camera was on knife just
being stabbed into
his what we're doing is predictive
programming as well it's just not as
subtle as putting it in a movie We're
actually just projecting what we think
is going to happen and that in a way is
prepping people for maybe believing okay
I'll get ready for what you think is
going to happen so we that's a big
responsibility and Luke I'm really glad
you brought off that show 24 yes Jack
Bower it was kef for Southerland it was
in 2003 right after world or uh
September 11th uh right after the towers
came down uh and it was like he was an
anti he was like fighting terrorists and
he was just such a good guy and there
was about to go off in New York City and
they needed to torture someone to save
everyone in New York City and then right
after that they're like oh we're
torturing people it's okay because we
want to save people from getting nuked
meanwhile they were torturing goat
herders that literally were sleeping
with someone's cousin that they didn't
like and The Afghani neighbor snitched
on them said that they're Taliban and
then they were sent to Egypt and
literally had their children I can't
even say this but you know hurt in
unspeakable Ways by CIA officials that
were torturing them in front of the goat
hurters there for freak's sakes that is
it's just mind-boggling to to to see the
level of just how Sinister this is and
and the the things behind the scenes
that actually do happen that that they
use to justify this kind of criminality
and Insanity we used to watch 24 CU you
guys watch Bush admin loves 24 so I have
fun I'll give a short version of his
story is don't kick me off from ever
coming back to Tim cast after to tell
tell you this so I once spent the day
with Carl Rove and his favorite show was
24 get out true story I don't care yeah
I know what do you like about it I I
think all the things tort torturing you
know you know going after we didn't get
into a lot I don't we get a lot of
detail this has been many years ago it
was like the show is 24 is all about 20
every episode there was 24 hours until
some horrible thing he was always in a
rush he was always a Race Against Time
no it was it was a real time wasn't it
like 24 was the episod that's right an
hour 10 to 11 what was bizarre to me is
I would have thought someone like Carl
Ro who's been in the places that he's
been and lived the life that he's lived
he would think like this Show's stupid
it's so fake it's so whatever but he was
like no this is a great show watch every
sing House of Cards did that too man
house of cards made us think that it's
okay for politicians to be corrupt like
it's like yo it's just how it is look
how Charming Kevin spy is in this too
it's okay he smiles the Pentagon
literally hires Hollywood producers and
writers to write scripts for them about
events that they then go to the American
people and say was truth they hired
Jeremy brookheimer to do the whole
Jessica Lynch story if you remember that
story that was an insane large scop on
the American people to push the Iraq War
to make everyone stand for this very
strong independent woman that stood up
and fought to the last Iraqi she stood
up on a Gunner and took them all down
when in reality she was cing in fear the
Iraqis took her to a hospital and said
hey America can you please pick her up
America send in tanks blew up the
hospital took her out and then the CIA
and Jerry brookheimer ran with a story
saying this Brave woman was saved by
American Heroes after she fought killing
the last Iraqi which is all bu I know
what the predictive programming is the
ma the main character the protagonist
what is their job save the world no
they're a journalist oh no they're
journalists and so already the trailer
narrative is civil war is bad
journalists are good gross here we go
the media is distrusted for years people
have hated the media Kirsten Dunst plays
a journalist and she's she has this line
it's actually a good line she says every
time I came back from a war I thought I
was sending home a warning and I'm like
I really like that she was saying the
warning was don't do this here
and I think the last time that maybe the
last time that happened was Vietnam I
can't think of the journalist name I'd
like name right now from Vietnam that
came back with some of those warnings
but U I wish a could name this is a good
I like the word Wars and the word
warning uh yeah don't do it here look
what happened in Ukraine look what's
happening in Ukraine that's what happens
when War happens destroyed I can't
believe these freaking lunatics that
were out there speaking screaming from
their rooftops that Ukraine could win
that war no they were lying and they
knew they were lying I don't know
anything about anything and I remember
early on I was like no that's there's no
way this is not going to happen only
country to get poorer after the fall of
Soviet Union and they're going to beat
Russia yeah come one of the most
corrupted countries in the world yeah
even if they won even if that it would
be so devastating was possible it was
never possible and I had I remember
having this conversation with people
like you just talk CU you love like I
don't like Putin it like you can look at
facts and just say this country is going
to get annihilated over time and that's
what's happening they' they've killed
off a generation of men in Ukraine this
is offensive somebody in the chat said
Alex Garland is a genius yes Tim didn't
pass the 11th grade that is shockingly
offensive I didn't pass the ninth grade
Who's Alex I can't believe you beat me I
want to say I'm around 10th grade I
dropped out of high school nice stop
showing off you guys I was home I can
actually top Tim on this I was
homeschooled and I dropped out of home
school that's tough to do I dropped out
a public school to be homeschooled so to
be fair the the reality is uh do you
have a GD no damn neither do I so
Alex Alex Garland's the guy that wrote
this is that right uh it's like it's a
writer director yeah okay he did
XM that's right
Annihilation I mean I'll definitely see
it for sure but but it's it's not like
I'm going like whoa this is I got to see
this movie I'm my attitude is like I'm
interested to see what their perspective
is and how they would portray yeah
because the power would be out I mean
none of these cities would have
electricity if there was a real war well
you don't think so of course it' be
power if Jets bombing I mean it would be
like power power will go out selectively
in key areas when infrastructure is hit
cyber attacks will take out certain
portions of the grid but there there
there are ways that things will be
backed up people I think it would be an
excuse for the CCP and Russia to go
Total War over the United States
Homeland and it would be like V2 like
rockets coming in out of orbit
Hypersonic destroy you you are right
there but not Total War not yeah total
it would be a limited war in in the
United States no they'd go to California
and say we will drop bombs on DC4 you
and then when it's over don't forget who
helped you they would want to maximize
influence with the
victors a c the United States would be
subservient to China yeah they would let
us destroy ourselves as long as we would
continue my concern would be like the
CCP would Aid the The Descent or
whatever the the Californian descent or
whatever I don't I'm not saying it's
California but just if there was a civil
war one side would be foreign Nationals
the other side would be the remnants of
the American government and the the
American government ones would be flying
their f52 whatever the hell these jets
are dropping bombs over the the denters
and the denters would have Chinese Jets
coming in over Washington DC and it
would be just roads would be all blown
apart there wouldn't be lights would not
be coming on in the cities the rivers
would become toxic it wouldn't be like
exciting it would be like no one would
know what was going on and they' just be
hearing bombs dropping and and planes
going overhead and
stuff yeah this is this is people to
people don't understand um and people
who have served in combat no better than
I imagine you're in the middle of a
shopping mall there's no people around
Civil War is happening you know what
happening you hear gunshots what do you
do you may be thinking in a movie you
know the bad guys are all running in and
you're like oh no it's the bad guys run
in the real world you hear gunshots and
you're like I don't know and then
someone runs in and you're like are they
a good guy or a bad guy are they on my
side or what do I do you don't know that
that's why Friendly Fire happens so
often they're they uh there's a famous
story I can't remember exactly what it
was there was um there's probably tons
of these stories an American unit
Vietnam was was being surrounded and
they're being shelled and they had to
get word out because they were being
shelled by Americans because the
Americans didn't realize that other
Americans were there these things kind
of happen these things these kind of
things happen a lot and that's like
you're when you're shooting at someone
that you don't realize then there's
things where like you just got dudes
walking in front of your tank and you
don't know they're in front of you I
think that was hamburger uh Mountain
that that incident happened in Vietnam
um that you were describing but but no
no information is the first casualty of
War so people you're right Ian won't
know what's going on and more
importantly they'll be given
disinformation to make them believe that
the opposite is true so whatever kind of
conflict is unfolding you might be
thinking you're doing the right thing
but you could have been fed information
that was totally not true at all people
get a radio broadcast that sounds like
Joe Biden but it's a deep fake G given
by the enemy you know like that kind of
stuff this is why uh so I just I
recently been watching Dr Stone and this
is why I love it so much one of the one
of the points of the show The the main
character is like we're going to build
the most powerful weapon known to man
Communications and I was just like yes
I'm like that is so amazing I love that
because the immediate assumption when
you say we want you're you're at War and
you're like what's the most powerful
weapon someone could have and they're
like I don't know nuke no a radio the
ability to coordinate in real time at
the speed of light is is I was thinking
this two nights ago Hamburger Hill
hamburger Mountain I just want
to go ahead the radio radio is like the
most powerful technology on Earth I mean
you could it is what was the Japanese
woman that used to broadcast dur in
World War II Rose something Rose I don't
know maybe I'll look it up I don't know
dude the radio
I was like in reading about Civil War
battles and stuff and American
revolutionary war fights it's like
that's why they had trumpets Tokyo Rose
Tokyo Rose there you go the reason why
they had drums the reason why they had
trumpets it was it was Battlefield
Communications you knew certain sounds
meant certain moves but now you have
radio yeah instantaneous long- range
communication radio like altered reality
and such broadcast towering like it just
things after 19 whatever 04 whenever
Tesla popped that and and there were
other people working on it too there's
an Italian guy working on it yeah but TV
Killed the Radio it definitely is better
but radio is like the basic function
like it's the basic groundbreaking
communication Tech that altered reality
in such a way and it still will like if
power goes out we have like shortwave
radio we can Bounce It Off the Radio
yeah you can connect around the world
with it what do ham high
altitude I don't know but it works let's
just find out yeah yeah crazy and and
you know what I kind want to tell you
Tim about civilization the game when you
develop that technology in the game Sid
Meyer had it right it changes everything
you get the broadcast tower and you get
battleships the ability to communicate
with your ships across the ocean like oh
dude you just cannot compete with
real-time communication yeah I I I like
10 guys with the same weapons as 100
guys could win if they're communicating
in real time at the speed of light like
I mean like instant communication is
other standing next to each other
because you can coordinate so much
faster it's ridiculous that that metric
I I just made I'm just saying hyp hyp
pathetically the you Communications
gives you such a tremendous advantage
over your opponent who can't coordinate
you're running circles around him well
it's the main weapon in fifth
generational Warfare and a lot of people
argue you know a lot of the posts a lot
of the social media uh a lot of just the
videos and the audio and the article
they're a lot more powerful than bullets
and bombs and I is the sword the
argument is absolutely true especially
what we're seeing now with the big
attacks against drumble the attacks
against Twitter the the attacks against
anyone willing to stand up for free
speech which I think is absolutely
crucial towards uh anti-war principles
that need to be promoted more than ever
those principles are only promoted on
Free Speech platforms meanwhile the
other platforms just promote War
conflict Bloodshed and Chaos I think the
reason communication Tech is is the most
powerful war technology is because
people don't want to fight they want to
end the conflict as fast as possible so
they're waiting for orders to figure out
how to do it and if you get the wrong
orders you're going to do what you got
to do to end the conflict if you do the
wrong thing like that you can that's the
most devastating outcome it like that's
that's I didn't think I just till just
now that's pretty deep dude people do
not want they want to end the kind it's
just like same with when you if you're
being attacked at night it's not about
what do you do if you're being attacked
it's not like kill it's like stop the
threat that is what it is get as far
away from it or whatever let's jump to
this story from Newsweek Elon musk's mom
rushes to defense she is furious with
Joe Biden well the real story is that
Joe Biden is targeting Elon Musk the
deep zate is targeting targeting Elon
Musk and now elon's Mom is calling out
Joe Biden saying I am the mother of Elon
Musk his goal is to make this world a
better place pus wants to stop him have
you any idea how Furious I am people in
other countries are proud of Elon and do
not understand the US president's motive
please tell me how I should answer them
that's the best mom tweet ever President
Biden stood at the White House Podium
and stated Elon Musk is worth being
looked at when asked how he said there's
lots of ways there certainly are the doj
FAA FTC nlrb sdny and FWS have all taken
action the FCC now now joins them it is
obvious that the federal government is
illegally and unconstitutionally
targeting Elon Musk over his political
actions who is Brenan Carter FCC who is
that he's I don't know if he's the
former let me pull him up he might be
the head of the
FCC he is the commissioner for the FCC
yeah what the hell and he's been calling
out the FCC quite a bit for the actions
they've been taking and he's and he's
announcing the FCC now joins them yep
wow that's a incredible threat yeah yeah
yeah no that's that's huge that that's
major and you know it's business when
your mom goes on social media and tries
to protect you and scold the people
attacking you but now that's incredible
thuggery from our government we we are
we are fullon Soviet style Hees
authoritarians oh do right he desent
okay good he says the FCC adds itself to
the growing list of federal agencies
engaging in the regulatory harassment of
Elon Musk I descent good for
him yo man but now he says the FCC is
going to be investigating them and he
says he's descenting to it he he this
guy this gu one of how many on the board
or whatever it is or whatever it might
be but uh yo they're going after Elon
man abely and this is why I like elon's
going to double down they've declared
war on a guy with means why is Alex
Jones back because they kept look the
advert Elon didn't want to bring Alex
Jones back because he didn't want to
lose advertisers advertisers pull out
and he goes screw itex back nothing more
dangerous than a man with Nothing Left
to Lose I'm not saying Elon Musk has
nothing left to lose but he had nothing
left to lose when it came to advertising
I I suppose it's fair to say there's
nothing more dangerous than the
wealthiest man on the planet with
nothing yes yes that is that's the
ultimate version of that for sure or
who's not Fe who who fears who who
doesn't fear Fe L this is so crazy man
the United States government I think has
I'm going to say it's such a dumb
obvious thing hubris like it's not that
powerful I know it is the probably the
most powerful government on Earth but
it's one of so many powerful governments
it's like you can't like win everything
you try and defend what our Venezuela as
well as the Ukraine as well as Israel
now you want to go after your own with
your richest uh citizen like what the
hell are you doing to yourself This I
want it to be good I want it to be a
force of good on Earth I I think Elon is
also we're we're a little ways off of
being the force of good
what what kind of drugs are you smoking
if you think government
be can't be good government has never
been good it's always horrible always
bad but I think Elon is banking on a
major election shift because if if let's
just say republican gets
into the executive office he's going to
make sure all of these investigations go
away but if Joe Biden is elected these
investigations will continue and they
will try to topple and destroy the only
platform that allows people to talk
freely to each other and expose the
scops as the scops happen Twitter is is
the place you go to get on the ground
breaking news coverage of events that
happen now and what better way to call
out the next SC up the next kind of
major event the next the next big Pearl
Harbor like event then of course be on
social media and you see it call that
right in right there in real time so I I
I I think he's understanding that there
is going to be a big political shift
he's banking on the Republicans the
Republicans
probably will win and then he's going to
be saved by them that's because there is
still a lot of fear of you know Apple
could come in and kill off Twitter X as
an app and that is a major major issue
Google Google can too and absolutely all
these things and and that's where too
big to fail quote unquote and correct
functionally but people would Apple
would never do it because people would
ditch their iPhones a lot of people
would I would I mean we still can't get
Republicans to vote in Prime Mar so I
don't know how far they're willing to go
to fight for things I or percentage of
them because screen time for for X is so
high it's not a question of I'm going to
take a stand it's a question of oh man
what did what did they say I I got to
get a different phone yeah it's not even
a question just use the web version or
whatever yeah if Apple removed it hurt
traffic and you could it would but a lot
of people would be like yo I'm on this
app 247 WTF mate yeah I'd like ruin my
life I'm going to watch it all day long
on Twitter just to just to teach the
government or apple this is why they
made threads they were hoping people
would switch but they will not no one
cared well this is why there's even
talks of Elon creating his own phone and
if he does then of course when
Apple everyone's going to go there but
then his networks what networks are
those phones going to operate T-Mobile
Verizon probably T-Mobile works with
everybody they're like screw it Cricket
like let's let's make it happen yeah
starink but Cricket but he has star too
so he he could he could merge his phone
with Starling if well he can't now but
if he could that would be the ultimate
that would give us true that's where
we're headed Inc I think starlink would
have the capabilities of um I I'd
imagine a phone could get a megabit per
second through starlink low orbit I mean
this the starlink he to expand it
greatly noet no I don't think so the
current starlink modules are small are
very small no no I'm saying you have to
span capacity where they are at
throughout you have to have more of it
up there is what I'm saying for it to
have connectivity I wonder what it's
current current could what what they
could handle but I imagine they could
easily get um texting texting no
question Starling could easily handle
text messages what would the delay I
mean these are questions I don't expect
low latency it's like 35 milliseconds oh
that's good that was the point of
starlink yeah satellite phones that's
that's definitely the future terrestrial
phones are too vulnerable these these
these landlines are can be just blown up
by a meteor strike I mean the ones up in
orbit yeah they're they're way safer in
orbit I think Apple already has a
feature where you could connect to a
satellite and case of emergencies when
you have no cell phone signal so you can
yeah and and for for a 10 years plus now
they've had two-way satellite texting
devices you know elon's got that in mind
that he's trying to merge all these
things into One X unit like the The
Starships the satellites the phones the
social media what else the tunnels are
going to be the shape big X underground
you're going to go through big X's no
just kidding they'll probably be circles
you saw those videos of the tunnels in
La no I haven't seen them yet you go
into a narrow tunnel in your Tesla and
it can bypass traffic self drives yeah
it's pretty terrifying yeah those tiny
tunnels I would not want to get stuck in
one of those things are they automate
like do they carry your car you have to
drive your car drives itself through oh
okay kind of actually it's like a little
sled thing his like final product is a
sled thing you drive the car on the sled
thing and then that automates the whole
process so it's all running on its own
rails you have to worry about driving I
would not want to go on one of those
yeah neither would I but if you live in
LA and you have to face traffic you
might you might you might want to
traffic in La is nuts dud dude some one
day I spent 3 hours in traffic going
like 10 miles or 17 miles what's the
fear of going in the tunnel you're going
to get stuck in the middle of it or that
little thing just going to shoot other
side yeah for a long time huh that'd be
rough real
rough what's their ventilation in that
thing I don't even know I don't even
like the tunnel like the Lincoln Tunnel
you know yeah it's not like I'm worried
about it I drive through drove through
it hundreds of times I'm just like those
long super narrow compressed tunnels I
don't know about that I was talking to
someone about this with building
skyscrapers we're going to this is going
to we're going to come a time there we
have a a crisis of Competency coming
we're already kind of there but we're
really going to be there in 20 to 30
years a crisis of Competency and I want
I'm I worry about the people making
building skyscrapers today what's going
to happen to those skyscrapers in 30 or
40 years go meet the average person
that's doing things anywhere in America
these days and it's going to get me
concerned about being on the H 100th
floor of a building built by these
people you can look at China today right
right now and see that happening in real
time and see the buildings that are
falling because people were skirting
around these little like building
building codes etc etc you know maybe
they just don't care about a loss of
life over there it's a little different
but I think it's like more of a they
they have probably or they do have more
competency when it comes to engineering
those kind of things than we have and I
think that they do I think 30 years from
now yeah so so just to go back to the
topic here I I think there's a race to
destroy Elon Musk will the Democrats be
able to do it during this election cycle
will they be successful can they stop
him can they stop Twitter what do you
guys think no no and at this pace
Trump's going to get elected and then
he's going to say thank you Elon and
elon's going to reap the rewards yep and
he's going to say oh all these
investigations what investigations Y and
rightfully so because he's being
targeted he's being attacked but uh I I
I think Elon is playing also a different
kind of Gambit as well when it comes to
the defense contractors when it comes to
the carbon emissions when it comes to
all the ties that he has uh to the
military industrial complex and to the
defensive capabilities that he's giving
Ukraine and Israel and the United States
in the Antarctica right now so uh I I
believe that's one of the reasons why he
is still not officially kind of taken
out officially stopped uh because uh the
Pentagon needs them someone needs screed
someone needs to ask Elon about verer
Von uh verer Von Bron's book what's the
book called uh what is it like Mars
colony or something I don't I remember
but it's where the colony of Mars the
government has an uh the president in
charges called Elon oh yeah and it was
written in 1948 before he was born um
that's wild I wonder if May knew that
and named Elon and then told him like
you'll do a colon that's I was saying
like you must colonize Mars and he was
like yes mother like they told Jesus
your father is God and he was like oh
really okay well I think he ran off for
a little while yeah he went when he was
14 true story oh wow allegedly true
story he just bounced out I wonder if
Joseph gave him his Blessing oh El
talking El or Jesus no we're talking
about Jesus I think right yeah everybody
was kind of pissed at him when he got
back back and he's like I was just doing
my work hey man sometimes the forest
calls you you just got to go East well
he's actually hanging out with villagers
but yeah that's awesome that's like
sidartha he just disappeared from his
life as a prince and went to hang out
with the commoners for long then he
became the Buddha later in life yeah I
want to know this okay we're colonizing
Mars how are we going to do it is it
going to be a corporatocracy where this
whole world is headed is corporatocracy
like our corpor so that's why the the
fascinating thing about verer Von br
book we were talking about it last week
is that he says the person in charge is
called the Elon and I'm like imagine
what happens with uh spacex's Mars
colonization project Elon Musk is the
boss he's in charge he controls the
finances and the resources so when
people are on Mars they're going to say
hey what are we doing with this new
shipment of cargo ask Elon and say okay
elon's going to get older and older and
older eventually he's going to say I'm
too old to keep doing this and then he's
going to pass on and some gu's going to
be like Elon passed who's in charge now
well our the next guy we have is you
know is Bill now we need someone who's
going to be the next Elon Musk who's
going to be our Elon Musk and someone's
gonna be like I think Rick would be a
good Elon and that's how Elon turns from
a name into a title or it could be an AI
that we call Elon that that we just kind
of as as a thanks I don't have to live
Omars it just seems even in tunnels you
don't have to yeah no but people who are
born there are going to love it you
think they're going to love it yeah in
their little tunnels like he's talking
about yes yeah because it's all it's all
they'll know
yeah that that obviously has a huge
impact I'm more of a beach kind of guy
to be honest I hope we keep things cool
here
Subterranean does yeah there's there's
uh nuclear silos you can live in that
have fake
beaches yep it's crazy Mars it's like a
big cylindrical thing with like 16
floors and one of the floors has like
this big curved fake Beach and okay Sun
like a good fake sun tan of this fake
Sun no oh damn Mars has um like flood
striations on the surface all over the
pl not all literally all over the
gravitation is too weak though so it
can't it struggles to maintain an
atmosphere yeah the core is still liquid
it's just got an outer layer of I think
nickel that's blocking the magnetic
field right now it's messing with the
field like 2020 science article about it
I think we should nuke the moon to alter
its trajectory so that over the span of
several decades it crashes into Mars my
guess is you know the the mar honest oh
God what is that that big trench on Mars
Mars giant trench it's just start
tearing the surface of the Mars trench
tear it's a the biggest Chasm on Mars
and it's like valis marinaris it was
like it looks like a scar like something
hit that planet ripped it open and then
magma just came out of it and just
spewed all into the atmosphere all the
water just the giant Global flood
catastrophe and then it just evaporated
and then the W the iron oxide in the in
the magma fell to back down to the
surface is dust and now it's coated the
surface as this red iron rust and
underneath it is all this ice and so if
we can heat it up rapidly I got faith
that it'll come back to
life is graphine going to play a role
absolutely uh Elon said to Nuke the
poles which I thought was an interesting
concept but but the my understanding is
the problem is the atmosphere is too
thin gravity is too weak to maintain it
so even nuking the poles would not Sol
you fire lasers at it just heat it up
with with like Electro lasers what about
like a Gra Caff superstructure
surrounding Mars to create a a an
artificial
atmosphere like a cyberdome but
surounding the whole planet yeah it' be
a lattice Network um with like magnetic
fields and stuff like that and then
redirecting heat like you could hit
lasers into that and then have it maybe
maybe just oh yeah you could create
potentially a a that's right that's the
future suitable habitat and it's like a
it's like a stage 01 Dyson Sphere okay
yeah once you have um drone construction
swarm construction you'll have like a
100 million drones all working in
Synergy building these horrifically
large structures in space because
gravity is not and space isn't it
doesn't matter how big it is you just
have 300 trillion drones working
together to construct it really quick
and then you can put these little arms
and like laser cutters and stuff and
they'll be moving things into position
yeah the features going to be wild yeah
I just want to make sure we're all here
to see it it's going to be exactly like
are you are you eating steak and lifting
weights cuz that's going to be the key
to your longevity okay I lifted weights
today I love it see you'll be around for
it I did arms I did shoulders and pecs
and and biceps two days in a row which
might have been a mistake but I just
like doing that I like those what do you
a couple years ago a day get to recover
I didn't want to a couple hold on a
couple years ago everyone thought we
were going to have flying cars we have
children that are eating Tide Pods do
you really think the future is bright do
you really think there's going to be
like some kind of we we we have all this
we can't even mention here on this
broadcast talk about the Mone I do think
it's going to be bright but it's like a
birth like we're giving birth to the
next evolution of the species and before
birth there's a contraction and I feel
like about if we if we're not going
through the contraction right now we're
going to and I don't want that to be a
nuclear war I want it to be some kind of
like you know at least like I just don't
want it to be a mass die off man we got
to be able to do something to preserve
these people well the mass die off is
happening now the population the
population is declining and um IQs are
going down too so there's that all right
everybody we're going to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net
but when you pre-order the song we're
going crazy guess what you pre-order at
the bestsong ever.com and you will
receive a code I believe you'll get it
on the 15th with the song you will get
35% off your uh cast brew.com purchases
so if you want coffee for 69 cents you
buy the song you'll get a unique promo
code that gives you 35% off and if you
subscribe with that code you will get
35% off your subscription
indefinitely see so so so for those
doesn't want to get the coffee Club it's
40 bucks a month use this promo code you
will get 35% off your membership forever
and I know he selling you on the code
but the song itself is worth 69 cents
song amazing how did the 69 number come
in pure coincidence so it was originally
99 Cents okay and there were people who
were like well we think we could sell
more of our new releases from lesser
known artists if it was cheaper then
there were some some other artists who
are like we're Super Famous we could
sell it for whatever we want so they do
$19.99 and 69 h we sell for $ 69 because
we want the sales we're less like we
we're in that argument of like Hey we're
not an established large band we're
trying to sell as many as possible let's
make it as cheap as possible for people
to buy I think you can also spend as
much as you want uh no you can buy one
song you can't spend more you can spend
more CH to give more want support the
company right I thought I thought you
may were saying you can buy more than
one no no so it's like pay what you will
you can give more than 69 cents if you
want here's what we want to do I think
if we sell around 50,000 songs we will
be on the Billboard Hot 100 with our you
know music industry mockery and that
would be like the main goal if we sell
500,000 Michael nolles Jeremy boring Tim
Po and Carter banks will all get a gold
record I don't know devastating to the
music industry absolutely devastating I
want to be a part of that Devastation
look we we we wrote songs and it's just
it's just music not everybody likes
every band it's fine you don't have to
like our music but when they when when
they emailed us saying go f yourselves I
was just like like I get it the way the
music industry is working right now is
they are trying to remove the capability
of new bands from entering without their
approval I just talked with Dicky
Barrett about it it's been like this
since the 80s it's been like this all
along you have to bend the knee and kiss
the pinky ring if you want access and
now that we're building networks outside
of their control they're getting angry
and telling us to f off it used to be
who decided what got played on the radio
our first song they didn't even track
like 1 million of the plays they went
oops sorry too bad and that knocked us
down we ended up being like number one
in a b in like digital sales and we
charted on a bunch of different like
rock and alternative charts and we would
have probably been number one in a lot
of different charts but they
accidentally said oh man this one didn't
count and then we wa a risis think about
it talk to Tom McDonald he's talked a
lot about how they've just rejected his
sales because they're desperately trying
to prevent anybody from getting into
their space without their say so so I
don't think we're going to sell 500,000
of these things but I I I believe the
daily wire is going to help in pushing
as well but it would be the greatest
thing ever to have a gold record yeah I
would we should put it in a movie in a
daily wire movie I'll talk to him about
it yeah that's a good idea uh Jeremy and
Michael nlls are in the video we put the
commercial up at uh timcast music on
YouTube and you can see the they deaged
themselves and made a fake video from
the 60s it's fun we're g to have fun uh
but let's read some super chats first
all right token black guy says first
congratulations you are first Tom
forsight says being first is for losers
clever cleverly done because you are
second in fact that was a risk token
then asks hey Tim longtime listener any
future plans to come down south possibly
I'm a Louisiana native and you have a
lot of followers down here maybe we can
find a time to do a show in
nin yeah I've never been I've never been
there before I'd love to go it' be fun
you go there you're from the south I've
actually never been down there a little
too dark for me time yeah Mar GR St
Louis James G says set any updates on
the Trump cans of your beer not upset
about any delays just curious as to the
new time frame for them to ship yes so
the Trump beer we ended up selling a lot
more of that than we originally expected
which is a good thing like millions of
dollars right yes I think around two on
the Trump beer yeah a little insane so
little unexpected but that is a great
thing we appreciate people being patient
so those have started going out it's in
order of people who ordered it was
originally a 45 uh day Delay from the
order to when it gets shipped that has
been extended check your spam so big
Tech does not like us very much so we've
sent out updates on this to people who
have ordered the Trump beer and for
whatever magical reason our order
updates go to spam which is not how
that's supposed to work so please do
that and uh be patient it is on the way
right on Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I
watched Crowder's Barber Shop video it
got me thinking about the need for and
importance of community I love that
that's the end goal for all these spots
we're putting together shout out my guy
right on that's the point we want to do
the casw coffee shops so that y'all are
meeting up and hanging out in person a
space where you can hang out talk about
things have the debates have the
conversations play board games whatever
it may be we want to this this is this
is the game plan man why are we doing
this music why are we doing coffee
imagine as I've said it a million times
for those that don't know you walk into
a coffee shop they got two TVs on the
walls left and right and as you're
waiting for your coffee it's Steven
Crowder playing it's daily wire it's
timcast it's Viva fry it's stick sexen
hammer and regular people who are not
listening to these accurate reports and
commentary will one day be like this is
pretty good who is this and they're like
oh that's that's step Crowder and
they're gonna go oh yeah I never heard
of him new subscriber and the idea is to
have like a thousand locations so we
want to just start popping these coffee
shops up all over the place where people
can hang out and also regular people
will be exposed to our media interesting
if on the screen while people are
playing there's a barcode that you can
scan to go to this subscription page on
there we could put a QR code I mean
everybody makes fun of CNN because they
the airport news network but think about
how how powerful that was for them they
were everywhere hotel lobbies I want to
take that so you'll have a strip mall
with a Walmart in it and there will be a
small Cas Brew Standalone in the middle
and people will be like I just want
coffee I don't know anything about it oh
coffee sure they walk in and then you've
got Tim Cyro playing or you've got stick
sex and Hammer talking also you can
Bluetooth into the monitors and they're
all silent but you can we'll play too
cuz eight different shows playing it's
not eight different shows it's one show
at a time okay so there will be five TVs
all playing the same episode of loud o
Crowder yep then regular people will be
Alexi in their coffee and they'll be
staring like huh how about I was
thinking about directed sound technology
I don't know if you can have like you
yes that's cool so there could be like a
seating area where if you sit down you
hear everything really well and if you
get up it gets a little fuzzier as you
walk away cuz then you could have like
relatively easy to do yeah you can do
like sound cancellation it's expensive
to engineer that stuff yeah
all right Mast mullet says great culture
War episode last Friday eschatology is
fascinating but accepting Jesus as your
savior is the most important thing
anyways help remove a tumor from my
dog's mouth go fund me Sammy boy's
dental surgery good luck sir good luck
to Sammy much you love to your dog
brother or Sam's the dog Jacob parody
says not that I didn't trust you in the
first place Tim but yesterday when pbd
said there's going to be a Cyber attack
my need to prep
heightened yeah that's a part of that
movie Leave the World Behind the the
Obama guessing yeah there's like a guy
in it is a prepper and they're like we
need to go to the prepper and take his
stuff I got to tell you man if you are
prepping and anybody knows you're
prepping when it all hits the fan you're
the mark mhh so you know good luck
everyone's like I'm coming to your house
and and you think they're joking they're
not yeah they're not joking what is
prepping I know nothing of this neither
you don't know about Spirit cooking you
don't know about prepping what is what
what is this conservative dad
conservative you got to be you got to
get down the rabbit hole what are you
doing bro he just doesn't know anything
about
I've lost all my guns do you know what
the Bohemian Grove is look all my guns
were lost in a boating accident and I
don't know what prepping is stay away
that's all I
know say uh urite says you keep saying
Texas didn't want to succeed but was
forced to because of geography wrong
Texas booted Sam Houston from office
because he was opposed to secession
Texas wanted it Texas was just as angry
uh well I'll clarify I'm not saying the
they didn't want to suceed they were
forced to I'm saying geography was a
principal reason for why they wanted to
secede they were the Confederacy was
next to them that were their trade
Partners in the immediate and they said
this makes the most
sense there you
go I think I think that was part of you
like you you list says Grant wrote about
that the emperor's Champion says I say
offer Bud Light clemency and the moment
they do something woke and stupid
boycott them and show these companies
what happens when they get
woke bzy says your thoughts on Matt
Walsh's take on your but light stance
also have you read the jaff memo in
regards to ways to control population
seems like it it's all come to pass I
have not and uh we did address the Met
wall segment I do think one of the thing
what my perspective is based on owning a
business and doing marketing and having
done marketing consistently for like I
don't know 15 some odd years or longer
and what I see with Bud Light is there's
going to come a point where they say
this market is closed to us how can we
increase sales and they're going to
Target other other political Market
spaces if conservatives say there's
nothing you can ever do to win us back
they'll say fine then we'll try to win
some some other people over who are more
more susceptible that could result in
them saying I think they just drop it
and they give the money to
Corona possibly and then Corona sponsors
a bunch of Pride events too they already
do I know and so the extra money that
budlight could be spending on UFC will
go to Pride defense they're not going to
look they that was a token offering to
say hey dumb conservatives we we think
you're stupid so we're going to give it
to what we see is your redneck God Dana
White and Kid Rock and you'll be happy
forever cuz you're all that's
but that was it's but it's they're
saying it to everyone but they already
they already sponsor and do those kind
they've been sponsoring boxing for years
right so I don't think it was a whole
new market for them really they just did
made deal out of it because it was Dana
White who Dana White who's not even a
republican by the way right so the issue
is either the Bud Light battle is over
it's done move on have a nice day and
there's no reason I ever talk about it
or you need to be on the offensive and
make statements about Bud Light and and
keep the pressure up but that's not
happening Kid Rock said it's over we
gave them a black eye that's what they
deserved now it's time to move on Dana
White saying they're the best buy their
product accepted $105 million you can
move on I think that's lost on people
though every I get I hear from this from
people all the time they're like oh did
you hear he sold out blah blah blah
still like Dan white but he sold out
that's what I'm hearing for I think
people need to boycott
UFC yeah this be a tough one exactly and
that's why budlight did it budlight
knows you you will not boycott UFC Luke
won't do it I like watching
no unbelievable I never said I would I'm
not I'm I'm admittedly in this so you
sees the narrative from them scream in
the woke faces they gave us what we
wanted and we win or you say I broke out
UFC I like you will not trick me point
out how Dana looked like a goofball
laughing and smiling and telling people
to drink gallons of alcohol I'm like
what for sure for sure super fake but
the fact that people won't boycott UFC
and I got to tell you I don't this show
does not have the influence step
consider that right anybody watching
this show can comment and say whatever
they want about the boycott by all means
please do so but y'all know UFC will
never be boycotted and people will make
up excuses for why they shouldn't have
to boycott UFC they're going to say oh
it's it's a false equivalence I mean UFC
isn't doing the same thing aligning with
a foreign corporation that pushed trans
ideology on children you're saying UFC
is in the clear okay have a nice day I
don't know no I I agree in that sense
like you can't even get Republicans to
vote in Republican primaries Scott
presler can he's done an incredible job
which is why we've teamed up with him oh
awesome yeah so our next Ultra right
beer can actually has a QR code when you
scan it it's going to go to Scott
pressler's organization to register
people to vote that guy's awesome yeah
he crushes it all right let's grab some
more Super chats what have we
here let's
see uh what do we have here Vos says bro
I hope all works out and dude is legit
but you drank something that someone
handed handed you out of the back of
their van unsolicited did it say free
candy on the side wait it said puppies
it did the THC number the dude from
zenjoy was actually I believe doing a
delivery to a uh a local uh a local
market and he was talking with the
owners about the the the the the product
drop off and he was like yeah I've got
some if you want it did he know you guys
before hand oh cool yeah he recognized
me and was like oh man would you try
some I'll be honest that stuff's
delicious and I want another one there a
big should I not drink too many of them
is that okay Luke you're the ashwaganda
guy the lavender one yeah I'm taking a
break from ashwaganda like people should
take breaks like a month at a time kind
of thing no I longer than that like take
a break for like 6 months to a year this
one is oh it's also got the lemon balm
yeah I'm not concerned about a dude who
is dropping off product to a store and
then I took some of the like a case of
the product that he was bringing to the
store that would have been pretty well
planned if this was the moment to take
out the Tim cast oh I like the honey
they use honey too that's cool yeah it
goes good in the spin drift which is
also a drink that I like I just respect
the Hustle Man Zen Joy is his drink and
uh D was working really hard working out
the back of his van that's the American
spear right I'll tell you the Alchemy of
this if you have spin drift or some
other delicious sparkling water with
real fruit juice and you add another
drink to it like a kombucha or perhaps a
zenjoy it's a nice expence he said and
this was this this is what got me he was
like you know he he wanted to help First
Responders firefighters police officers
relax cuz he knows it's a very stressful
job and he he goes and he gives them out
to them for free and then I was like oh
you sold me easy definitely we shout you
that's that's awesome thank you cool
stuff dang but but really really all all
that matters the dude was on the hustle
man he was working hard he's an
entrepreneur I really yeah we should
order like a hundred of these or
something definitely we should order a
bunch yeah I think we will we'll order a
bunch of them they're good yeah but I
think Luke was saying be careful with
the ash gandi can't do too much yeah
just do it um that makes me want to do
it now I'm going to look into this more
yeah what have to check they sell
gummies you can buy at the store it's
just like an herb it's in a lot of
supplements so you just want to make
sure you're not consistently taking it
more than a month some some doctors
Mainline professionals say three months
I say one month just to be safe you're
not a medical professional so it's just
all right we got an important one here
Dylan vastaan says what's the carb
content of ultra right
beer uh don't want to get this wrong 135
I believe carbs oh no I'm sorry I I was
like thinking I'm
think calm down everyone stop that no
talking calories here so it is not a
light beer by the way it's a full logger
but it's a lightful logger and I should
have the carbs in front of me I'd have
to dig through my email to find that
we've had a probably like 17 or
something I don't know I don't remember
exactly what it is I'm not going to say
something wrong people are Los their
mind is is there any fluoride in there
most beers have a lot of
fluoride no uh oh are you sure about
that the water comes out of Florida you
have to talk to Ronda santis about that
is it tap water
no but okay so it's heated and boiled to
a point where he's going he's he's have
a problem with any freaking thing I say
about organic filter it's distilled
water it's it's he I guess that would be
considered if it's heated and boiled
does that make it distilled I I believe
so no distill does if it if it boils and
then Rec condenses if it just boils it
you'll kill some bacteria and stuff but
it doesn't really it won't remove flid
you need like silver filters to get out
floride out of the water reverse fils
seriously reverse osmosis it's it's not
easy but uh it's it's pretty cool you
could like an unflor dat
version work on some kind of like health
alternative together uh I'm actually
open open to this so I there's some
things that we are working on that I
can't say right now on air but I will
talk to you about that maybe we could do
some um I have a good idea I know what I
want to do let's talk about it off air
let's talk about it off air it's it's
some something healthy we would agree on
this yeah yeah so let's partner maybe
let's talk about this off Ultra right
bone marrow beer juice with beef
smoothie
baby Aran had a a a beef liver smoothie
it was incredible it was really really
really good they discontinued it uh the
liver smoothie at
Aran they partnered with Paul saladino
really good I like Paul saladino let's
talk about that let's do the lowski beef
liver um smoothie if you get Luke's face
on a can dude I'm so in my nose won't
fit it'll
w F says just bought $70 sample of packs
from zenjoy to bring to work GG this
product is for the boys boys boys boys
boys Bo it's really good the lavender
you can really taste the lavender it's
it's spectacular Lavender is not good
for your testosterone well I'm just
having a little bit Doc Holiday says all
that work in the gym D says one year ago
Luke said he will never vote for Trump
ah I don't think I I said that let him
live it's okay I I think we should be
critical I think we should hold
everyone's feet to the fire I don't know
exactly what I said um please show me
what I said and then I'll be more more
able to of course react to it but uh
everyone deserves to be
criticized K says Luke who did you vote
for in
2020 Trump you vote for Trump in 2020 MH
yeah see why people talking about yeah
there you
go Doc Holiday says $20 for Tim calling
Luke out and exposing his Trump
derangement
Sy voted for Trump he said he voted for
Trump I voted for Trump that's f
so J Rob says Tim did you happen to see
the video of the former FBI agent
warning VI to be very careful implying
that someone might try to off him I saw
it you know I don't know what what he
what are you supposed to think about
that right what was it a video of the
actual a guy met him and was like be
careful cuz you know that's reasonable
for anybody running for president Dark
Days i' I'd like to know the scenario
the movie came up with that Texas and
and California would be
United that's how they get you to watch
the movie right right it's smart no
that's how Tim gets you to watch the
movie he's the secret he's been the
salesman all along yeah like it takes
people to speak up like theic and Elon
it takes people to speak up but it takes
people to build the systems quietly as
well because if if you're always just
pushing people up into the front of the
line like those are the most vulnerable
as well as the bravest so there's a lot
of Engineers and things that are
Building decentralized Systems that can
back up the the wants of these people
for
Freedom all right William H says
pre-ordered on itun iTunes and Amazon
usually wouldn't do that but I wanted to
inflate that middle finger to the music
industry cheers fellas yeah so just to
quickly reiterate again the original
idea was a song called is this what you
want and it was supposed to serve as
this like cheesy song where it's like is
this what you want girl and it's like
just like Club synth pop is this what
you need oh my voice is just
really kill and the real point was that
the is this what you want question was
the insult to the music industry like is
this what you want from us is this what
we have to do and so will stop insulting
us and then uh when I saw together again
from the daily wire I was like no no
we're going to do a modern it's it's
like in the style of the weekend like we
we're basically the whole thing is a
parody of blinding lights Tyle one in
chat if you want to see me Tim and
Carter do is this what you want in the
style of Back Street
Boys no no no not back stre boys that's
old school wait a second that's old
school why would I want to do oldies we
want to do more like post Malone can you
do a heavy metal one in the future I
feel like that that would heavy metal
doesn't have a so in the future I mean
sure we we we've got heavier rock songs
a lot of the stuff we're were putting
out is just like basic Rock and and they
tell us to screw off and go off
ourselves so we're like let's make
modern synth pop as an Fu to them and
we'll team up with the daily wire with
their Fu combine them and like here's
the thing it's more of an inside joke
the song doesn't directly say F you or
anything like that it's beautiful we're
just doing it to get it on the billboard
and be like boom there you go in your
faces like the idea is to make some that
charts well enough to where they have no
choice but to write about it devastating
to I want somebody I'm not going to name
the news outlets but a bunch of them
told us to f off like quote go f
yourselves some of us called us like
Maga chuds and things like this I want
their Editor to be like I need someone
to write this up and they're going to go
no
no they game the system yes and this is
why I was like teaming up with Jeremy
boring and Michael nolles will be bigger
because how do they reject a story now
about all of us yeah it's one thing when
they're like screw Tim pool we're not
going to write this up it's another
thing when they're like no Jeremy we're
not going to work with you now all of us
have this song could you imagine if we
got a gold record office yeah it'll it
the the the they'll come for perspective
that you gamed the system that's what
they won't say no I understand it's it
is great but that will be their
narrative if it it's in a movie does it
contribute to the gold record sales like
say do movie tickets if it's in a movie
do tickets to the movie count they have
to buy the song or listen to the song if
you listen to the song one time that's
great if you buy the song it's
equivalent to 150 down uh plays that's
why purchases are so powerful and a lot
of people a lot of big artists struggle
to get any sales at all like the the big
the big the big uh artists obviously are
getting like 200,000 sales on their
albums when they release them but the
average artist even like look you you
name a mid-level band you've heard of
that's playing big festivals even
potentially headlining and they're not
getting sales at all yeah they're
getting put in Rotation by labels
the plays that they get like when you
look at the charts you're like how did
that artist I've never heard of Hit the
Billboard Hot 100 the label that owns
the rights of the music goes to the the
the streaming platforms and says if you
want top artist you must put lower
artist in rotation rotation guarantees
they'll hit the charts because and
that's how people find music these big
Industries tell us to screw off and they
will not I mean look we release a song
We're number one on iTunes worldwide we
are we're number one in digital sales
and we are not appearing anywhere on any
of these platforms or stations in terms
of their trending or anything even on
YouTube They Weren't properly
categorizing us and the the tracking
said our video didn't qualify it's like
they I'll put it this way look at Tom
McDonald he's talked about it quite a
bit he puts a song out and gets five
million hits in a week and they're like
Noe you don't chart they're just they're
just basically trying to Stonewall I'm
trying I'm like let's just flick them
off and make it undeniable they cannot
win this one we're going to win win this
one I love that yeah we got to get it to
play uh globally overseas that's where
the markets cuz these American markets
like just it's in it's inclusive what
happened was um what was that what was
that one song that was like on the
charts for months what was it sunroof I
don't know yeah I think it was called
sunroof and that's what we were like
this is it this is what the industry
wants and we'll put out and we'll go
International so let's make some like
Club Mix garbage this is what you want
and then just blast it with marketing I
can see Carter's music going hot in
Germany or like France like it's it's
definitely
dhof not yet but have you seen his arms
man he's
ripped Carter s Reaper says instead of
budl giving money to UFC the boycott
stops when they donate to the families
of the victims of the Nashville shooting
who are impacted by the trans ideology
that they
pushed well there you go that would just
require a coordinated effort so that
would mean right now instead of just
saying we will continue the boycott it's
what's the next move if if the argument
as Ian has pointed out is that they're
fleeing the battlefield you can't just
stand there now we have to say what's
phase two in the we are mad at Bud Light
shoot them with in the back as they flee
I don't know that's probably rout it
just depends on what you want to do
right but what does that mean what does
that what does that literally mean does
does it mean uh uh does it mean making
videos about Bud Light does it mean
demanding budlight apologize does it
mean uh
uh I don't know I don't know what it
means does it mean going to Bar and
telling them to boycott Bud Light it's
like do you want to hurt their sales
further or are you satisfied with this
dip so that they don't do it again in
the future it's a pretty solid dip I
think most people will be satisfied with
that long term come April the sales are
going to normalize no no the sales are
not going to normalize no no sales have
normalized already they've normalized to
the new low yes six months seven months
ago they did I I understand but that's
not normalized for what they've been for
decades now that doesn't mean anything
yeah it does it means Revenue it means M
it means Ian's mom is going to say but
the boycott didn't work okay and you're
the the beer guy is going to say call
you out Becky no listen I I am telling
you this I guarantee it because Ian told
us the story over and over again and I
think Ian would agree when the news when
the New York Times MSNBC and CNN report
Bud Light sales have jumped to plus 2%
and their stock is higher than ever
Ian's mom that's just admitting we're
going to admit defeat on every lying
narrative that the left string media
sends at us no I'm saying what's the
next move to counter this
they're still down your mom watched on
that doesn't mean anything to Ian's mom
well I I don't care about Ian's mom no
if it's your
Momen to how do you win a culture War if
you don't care about regular Americans
no I I didn't say I didn't care about
regular americ regular American is going
to all she does is watch CNN and MSNBC
and so how do we win the narrative how
do we win the culture War we need to
take people who who right now the
narrative needs to be indistinguishable
unequivocally everyone goes wow budlight
they they they're they're done and you
think you're going to win The Narrative
with Shan Strickland or any of these
other Alternatives needs to make a
statement you need either either you say
right now we won or you double down
there is no do nothing but you think we
saying we won here at timcast is somehow
going to get dispersed among MSNBC and
CNN they're going to say well they won
yes Tim claimed it yes I yes I do I feel
like the issue is you're acting like I'm
the only one saying it no I'm saying I
with kid saying you're the only one
saying Kid Rock comes out and says no
but no one buys it from Kid Rock or Dana
because took 105 they always freaking
lose because they most conservatives
best name of them starts with with I'm
not going to ever stop trying and that's
why our company's given 150 Grand this
year which is nothing care about what's
phase two phase two is continue holding
the line that means do nothing D bu do
nothing means stop by buying a
product no but done it for 30 years in a
already stopped buying now what they you
could consider it a fortification tactic
so we've taken the line they've fled now
we fortify this area that we want what
I'm telling you is that come April
budlight is going to Stage another
frontal assault going no they're not
going to do any s you think they're
going come out the dilm of any adud no
I'm telling you the media is going to
report in April the boycott lost and
people like Ian's mom are going to hear
that and tell you it doesn't work
they're going to go to the marketing
departments at their companies and their
Tech outlets and say boycots don't work
do you think is going to say we won this
so much we're coming out with a deal in
lad 2 that's not what I said bull I'm
asking that's what I'm asking now let
let's actually let's actually argue what
I was saying I'm let's argue what I'm
actually saying when CNN the New York
Times MSNBC and all these big media
Outlets that we are constantly battling
with over narrative control report to
the average American the boycott failed
the their their their stock is back
above where their Stock's already back
exactly and then they so you CLA Victory
now and then they're going to say and
yes you declare Victory now because they
just while the Stock's already back
because it came back because they gave
us what we wanted then you you can't
they happened two days ago or whatever
the hell it was you can't say the stock
didn't just come back in the last two
days the stock came back in November
before this happened before what
happened the whole uh day the UFC no the
UFC thing was November the stock started
to
rebound within the last week you're
saying no no no the stock rebounded in
November around the time the UFC deal
was announced around the time or before
or after around it's I mean if you want
to track day by day you can go look well
that's what we'd have to do to make an
argument so the narrative is going to be
among average people who are working for
big companies conservatives can't hold a
boycott this is going to happen and I'm
asking you what your plan is I I think
that I won't even tell you what to do by
all means don't buy Bud Light I'm asking
you what is your plan again I think if
you go back to if you're if you're going
to say the plan is that we if if they
are still down 20 something per in April
and so the media is going to come out in
April they're going to say we're up 2% I
understand from being just like we've
had to do with the and everything else
no one knows that unless we're out there
pushing but I'm just not going to not
tell the truth because I'm afraid no no
one ever said don't do that that's not
the I'm just going to make a dis
argument is what is what is the plan for
the media's play in April they will do
this what's your strategy the strategy
is to give the the Nar the opposite
narrative or to give the truth to what
that is I'm not saying the truth always
wins it doesn't always win right I'm
going to fight for the truth going
forward that's our deal at our company
that's that's not even that right I
don't I don't disagree the point is what
is the the strategy for comp competing
against a widespread medion Aire of
especially the beer industry we're going
to see the beer trekking companies that
reported the loss reporting budlight has
is recovering their stock is up and
their growth is here okay but I so I
know the people in the beer industry
they are down a crapload of money right
now they're not going to be able to
these Distributors who are what does
that to do with what I said
these Distributors who are down 30
something something percent right now if
they're only down 20 something percent
and a few mons they're not going to be
able to pretend is back they have
advertising dollars per case of beer
that is sold they have a certain amount
of money that they're giving back from
these big Distributors so we want the
message to be for all corporations if
you support Dylan mulany we you will
lose
money which would be exactly what that
except come April their stocks recovered
and their sales are in growth
a a 0.2% sales growth is not enough
to we're making up any number but but it
doesn't matter stocks recovered and the
company is growing they're going to say
the boycotts over you cannot say the
company is you can say you can play word
games to say it's growing when you're
when you're still 25% less than you were
a year before no in April year over year
a year and a half before you're 25 April
year-over-year they will see growth
that's the point you can make the claim
of growth but you're still down 25% for
from what you've been for decades but
that's not the point the point is no
that's a big point to distribut getting
we want to win a culture War not a beer
War the beer is a component of the war
it's a single battle if they run this
narrative what's the plan I so so you're
just saying so we have to always fight
be on defense for any lie the mainstream
media wants to make up and saying what's
what's your offensive strategy again the
truth but that's not you're saying words
what what are you going to do you're
saying all they're going to say his
words which the media is going to M
report beer sales numbers are up and
they're going to they're not going be
able to say that beer sales numbers are
up yes they are fact over over a year
over year yes fact okay so we we got
wiped out a year ago and we've come back
this much which means the boyc over that
does not take a lot to argue that and so
you're going to see across the board
conservative boycott fails Bud Lights
and growth they're going to have their
spokesperson come out and they're going
to say we can see after a long time our
our mission and just everyone's going to
be silent and no one's going to respond
to that and say hey by the way they're
still down 25 is anyone going to boycott
UFC is anyone going to call out white is
call conversation now I'm saying who's
going to speak up well I'll speak up on
timcast when I can right my point is
this there has to be a strategy and
right now the only strategy people has
and all of the chat is I will do nothing
as if and that will destroy a brand as
it has there are already diverting
hundreds of millions of dollars of
advertising outside of the budl brand
and they're giving it to other companies
within their organization obviously
right so then we need to declare Victory
I think it's already a victory yeah I'm
not Nar needs to be we won have a nice
day that's my point what's what's the
plan the plan is either we say we win or
we go on the offensive no I I think we
say we won and we continue the boycott
sure and you just continue marching you
don't go into you don't pursue the route
you just you you to settle the area and
then you continue the March which is the
boycott I mean I don't know about this
analogy but sure analogy is you win the
battle they flee you can either chase
them down by boycotting all of their
brands or you can hold the line and then
continue the March which is holding the
boycott rather than be like rather than
telling people to buy beer which is a
retreat you just continue the March you
you do not buy Bud Light
correct that's a that's a option where
are you marching to now we're just
getting weird I I feel I feel like the
end result of this is the the the impact
of the Bud Light thing it was over as of
like June the sales that were gone
aren't were gone nothing else happened
after that just narrative stuff just
periodically being like oh wow some guy
got fired someone resigned since then
nothing has really happened and so we
can be like we did it but there needs to
be a like this this is why I think we AB
talking over each other a little bit I
absolutely believe we claimed Victory
and this is why Kid Rock said we did it
guys we gave them the black eye but the
difference is they're going out and say
go buy it again Dana White is Dan that's
I'm sorry Rock was bit more flid and
just like look we gave him the black guy
they deserved it we got what we wanted
out of it okay and so with Kid Rock
saying that as the guy who opened fire
on the Bud Light which really created
the viral moment which led to a
widespread boycott you can now say ha
haa we win when we boycott we get what
we want right terrify all the other
companies and say we'll get exactly what
we want if you cross us but I think if
if you let $105 million say hey we're
going to start buying it all again I
think you lose it real quick we just pay
them off then Dana White needs to be
publicly called up by everyone at every
Point agreed all right we got to go to
the the members only show let me say
this about my mom because we used her an
ex it's very clear as a as the Normie
perspective they see the news they
believe what they see but she's also
intelligent enough that if you explain
they're down 25% from 10 years and
they're going to say 2% to make it look
like they're growing she'll understand
immediately that that's B crap right
should and my point is I want the guy
who works at you know wonderbrad to be
like oh man if we do these campaigns
we're going to lose a lot of money if
the narrative inverts because everyone
just stops and does nothing and says
nothing they're going to say oh but
didn't that thing fizzle out I just saw
on CNN they said that their their sales
are up and their stock is at an all-time
high we'll have to look for articles
when they claim Revenue increase and
call it out and already their stock has
completely recovered and then we can do
the numbers on top of what they were two
years ago and be I I got to beon 2% down
27% so you're down it it is wild that
their stock has completely recovered
despite being down in yeah in early
November it jumped from 55 to 65 in like
half a month guess Bill Bill Gates
bought a lot of stock but that wasn't in
November all right we got to the members
show so smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net thank you so much for coming
on we'll start that conversation on
fluide very soon but thank you so much
for coming on it was awesome my YouTube
channel is youtube.com/ we are Chang
I've been working really hard on that
YouTube channel I do lives I do shorts I
do videos there's 20 plus years of
videos on there uh click the channel and
click most popular be prepared to be
surprised today's video was on the dark
history of Harvard uh I'm somewhat close
to a million subscribers it would be
cool to have subscribe youtube.com/ we
are changing I'm Ian crossin uh and I
apologize for the the grainy voice I was
therapeutically screaming Pearl Jam 10
the other night doing a release oh it
felt so good I mean it just really felt
good and uh speaking of musicians with
grainy voices I interviewed Dicky
Barrett today from the defiant fantastic
human on my YouTube channel X Channel
things like that so go subscribe to me
all over the Internet and check out that
interview with Dicky it was a lot of fun
I love you guys Serge take it away yeah
you looked to me when you musician with
h granny voice my voice is kind of
Grinny right now too so I was like oh
okay cool but uh yeah cheers mate um
let's get to the after show Tim we'll
see you all of we will see you all at
timcast.net